This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K House Deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blair an oasis and looking forward to buying their first houses and that of course takes us to mortgages. Now the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer.
本集由劳埃德 5K 首付贷款赞助播出，这种贷款方式自 1996 年以来就再未出现过。是的，所以20世纪90年代现在看起来就像是一个失落的繁荣与乐观的黄金时代，对吧？想想1997年布莱尔政府的上台，围绕它的那种热情和兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术发展，以及那种仿佛无尽的金色夏日的感觉，每个人都在听着布莱尔和绿洲乐队的歌，期待着买下他们的第一套房子，这自然就把我们带到了按揭贷款。现在的好消息是，为了向90年代致敬，劳埃德银行正为首次购房者提供5K首付按揭贷款。所以请搜索“5K首次购房者”。
1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments. and conditions apply. Right now, for a limited time, everyone's part of the Buick team, even you. Buick's employee pricing for you event is on now. Get a purchase credit of up to $3,168 on a 2026 Buick Envision. Surround yourself with signature Buick refinement from an available massaging driver's seat to an expansive panoramic moonroof and a stunning ultra-wide 30-inch diagonal screen.
1996年平均首次购房者首付数据基于英国国家统计局（ONS）。受信用状况限制，如果您未能按时还款，您的房屋可能会被收回。适用相关条款与条件。现在，在限时活动期间，每个人都是别克团队的一员，甚至包括您。别克的“为您员工定价”活动正在火热进行中。购买 2026 款别克昂科威，即可享受高达 3,168 美元的购车优惠。从可选的按摩驾驶座椅到开阔的全景天窗，再到令人惊叹的超宽 30 英寸对角线屏幕，让自己沉浸在标志性的别克精致感中。
Don't miss Buick's Employee Pricing for You event. Visit puik.ca for more details. My name is Peter Parker, but I'm also... Spider-Man. This Thursday, we're faced with a threat. That can be anyone. The world may have forgotten Peter Parker. I'm just a neighbor.
千万不要错过别克的“为您员工定价”活动。访问 puik.ca 了解更多详情。我叫彼得·帕克，但我也... 是蜘蛛侠。本周四，我们将面临一个威胁。一个可能是任何人的威胁。世界可能已经忘记了彼得·帕克。我只是个邻居。
Friendly neighbor. But he hasn't forgotten them. Sometimes Spider-Man has to do the hard thing. That's my responsibility. Dr. Banner? I didn't know you could get that big. Spider-Man, brand-new day. In theaters Thursday.
友好的邻居。但他并没有忘记他们。有时候，蜘蛛侠必须做艰难的事。那是我的责任。班纳博士？我不知道你能变得那么大。蜘蛛侠：崭新的一天。本周四上映。
Cousin is he, I know him by his look. See where my soldier shot him through the arm. He missed him near, but we have struck him now. Ah, thou base degenerate, chief standard bearer to the Lutherans. Thus, in despite of thy religion, the Duke of Guise stamps on thy lifeless bulk. Away with him. Cut off his head and hands, and send them for a present to the Pope. And when this just revenge is finished,
他莫非是表弟，我从他的长相就认得他。看我士兵的枪是怎么打穿他胳膊的。他差一点就打中，但我们现在已经击中他了。啊，你这个卑鄙堕落的家伙，路德宗的首席旗手。就这样，顶着你的宗教信仰，吉斯公爵踩在你毫无生气的庞大身躯上。带他走。砍下他的头和双手，作为礼物送给教皇。当这场正义的复仇完成之后，
unto Mount Focon will we drag his corpse. And he that living hated so the cross shall being dead be hanged thereon in chains. Now no delay. Go and shoot the ordinance off. That they which have already set the street may know their watchword. And then toll the bell. And so let's forward to the massacre. Chilling.
我们将把他的尸体拖到蒙福孔。生前如此痛恨十字架的那个人，死后也将被用铁链吊挂在上面。不要再耽搁了。去把大炮放了。好让那些已经占领街道的人知道他们的暗号。然后敲响钟声。就这样，让我们向大屠杀迈进。不寒而栗。
So that was the sinister Henri or Henry, Duke of Guise, as ventriloquized by Christopher Marlowe in his tragedy, The Massacre at Paris, which he wrote in 1593. And what that play describes is the most infamous bloodbath in all 16th century European history. It is the massacre, the pogrom against French Protestants, or Huguenot, as they were called, which began on the 24th of August 1572. to St. Botholomew's Day. And Marlowe was writing his play two decades later, but the events of that day,
这就是那个阴险的吉斯公爵亨利，由克里斯托弗·马洛在他1593年创作的悲剧《巴黎惨案》中通过腹语所表现的形象。那出戏所描述的，是16世纪整个欧洲历史上最声名狼藉的大血案。这就是针对法国新教徒（当时被称为胡格诺派）的大屠杀和Pogrom（大暴动），始于1572年8月24日，即圣巴托洛缪节。马洛在二十年后写下了他的剧本，但那一天的事件，
the bloodshed in the streets of Paris, were still stamped onto the imaginations of English Protestants. They haunted their dreams. Because this was the proof, proof beyond any possible doubt, that Catholics were set on extirpating the true religion, the true Protestant faith, that they were plotting and conspiring to destroy Protestantism,
巴黎街头的流血事件，仍然深深印刻在英国新教徒的想象中。它们萦绕在他们的梦中。因为这是铁证，是不容置疑的铁证，证明天主教徒决心根除真正的宗教、真正的正教信仰，证明他们正在密谋策划摧毁新教，
and that if they were ever given the opportunity, there was no atrocity, no barbarism, no crime, no cruelty that they would not commit in the name of their hellish fanatical devotion to the Bishop of Rome and his underlings. And Tom, people may be thinking, well, this is very overstated and very melodramatic, but actually what the Duke of Gies is promising in that speech, the massacre. You know, he's punished this bloke. What's happened to this one guy is going to happen to thousands of other people. I mean, this is not so far from the reality of what actually
并且如果一旦有机会，为了他们对罗马主教及其下属的那种地狱般狂热的忠诚，他们将不惜犯下任何暴行、野蛮行径、罪行和残忍虐待。汤姆，人们可能会觉得，这未免太夸张、太戏剧化了，但实际上吉斯公爵在演讲中所承诺的那场大屠杀。你知道，他惩罚了这个家伙。在这个人身上发生的事，将会发生在成千上万其他人身上。我的意思是，这与当时在巴黎实际
did happen that day in Paris, is it? Yeah, as we'll see, Marlowe is drawing on contemporaneous accounts for his drama. And even though in the play, the Duke of Gies is a kind of classic Tudor, dramatic Machiavelle kind of cackling and all of that. And, you know, The words in his speech do correspond, as you said, to what happened. So the guy who was shot through the arm at the beginning of that speech, and then he gets dispatched by Gies's men and the Duke of Gies himself kind of jumps on him. So that is the Admiral of France. And we talked about him in our previous episode.
发生的事情的现实相去不远，对吧？是的，正如我们所见，马洛在他的戏剧中借鉴了当时的记载。尽管在剧中，吉斯公爵是一个经典的都铎时期、戏剧化的马基雅维利式的人物，会发出那种咯咯的笑声等等。而且，你知道，他演讲中的词句确实如你所说，与发生的事情相吻合。所以，演讲开头那个胳膊中枪的人，随后被吉斯的手下干掉了，吉斯公爵本人也跳上去踩了他一脚。这就是法国海军上将。我们在上一集中谈到过他。
He's a very distinguished soldier called Gaspar de Coligny. And the reason that the Duke of Gis is so triumphant as he stands over the corpse of Colini, as he is in the play, is because Gies, although by now he's 21, so still a very, very young man, he is the most powerful Catholic nobleman in France, and Colony is the leader of the Huguenots, the French Protestants. But as we also mentioned in our previous episode, Gies's hatred for Colony is personal as well as sectarian, because he blames the Admiral for having sponsored the assassination of his father nine years. before. And so listeners may be wondering, well, there is this intense ideological and personal hatred
他是一位杰出的军人，名叫加斯帕尔·德·科利尼。吉斯公爵站在科利尼（剧中正是如此）的尸体上时之所以如此得意洋洋，是因为吉斯虽然当时才21岁，仍然是一个非常非常年轻的人，但他却是法国最有权势的天主教贵族，而科利尼则是胡格诺派（即法国新教徒）的领袖。但正如我们在上一集中也提到过的，吉斯对科利尼的仇恨既有宗教派系的原因，也有私怨，因为他将九年前自己父亲遭暗杀的事情归咎于这位海军上将。因此，听众可能会想，既然吉斯公爵和科利尼之间存在着如此激烈的
between the Duke of Gies and Colony. What on earth are they doing in the same city? Why are they in the same place if there's this civil war raging on? They are there because a ritual has been celebrated, which it is hoped may end the civil war in France between Catholics and Protestants. And it's a wedding between a Catholic and a Protestant. So the Catholic is the sister of the French king, Charles the 9th, Charles the 9th. And she has married the Protestant king of Navarre, who inevitably is also called Henry. And as a rule of thumb in this period in France, almost everyone important is called Henry. And there will be more to come.
意识形态和个人仇恨，他们到底在同一个城市里做什么？如果正爆发着内战，他们为什么会在同一个地方？他们在那里是因为人们庆祝了一个仪式，希望这个仪式能结束法国天主教徒和新教徒之间的内战。这是一场天主教徒和新教徒之间的婚礼。天主教徒是法国国王查理九世的妹妹，即查理九世。她嫁给了纳瓦拉的新教徒国王，此人不可避免地也叫亨利。作为这一时期法国的一条经验法则，几乎所有重要人物都叫亨利。而且未来还会有更多。
People will be excited to learn. A colony, the Protestant, has been invited as a particular guest of honour. So there's this idea that Catholics and Protestants are going to. to be reconciled. Now, Gies, who strongly disapproved of this wedding, he has seized his chance for vengeance. So first of all, he sponsored this assassination attempt on Colony, and this was the shooting that had left Colony, as Marley puts it, shot through the arm. And then two days later, Gies sends a death squad to attack Colony directly in his rooms. And they arrived there, and they find that a unit of musketeers have been stationed outside the doorway leading up to Colony
人们会兴奋地得知。新教徒科利尼作为特邀嘉宾被邀请出席。因此，人们有一种想法，认为天主教徒和新教徒将要和解。然而，强烈反对这场婚礼的吉斯，抓住了他复仇的机会。首先，他资助了针对科利尼的暗杀未遂事件，这就是马洛所说的让科利尼胳膊中枪的那次枪击。接着两天后，吉斯派遣了一支敢死队直接去科利尼的房间袭击他。他们到达那里后，发现一队火枪手正驻守在通往科利尼
quarters, and they've been sent there by the king on Charles the Ninth's orders to protect a colony against any threats from Catholic intruders. But the musketeers, when the Duke of Geese's men arrive, they go, brilliant, let's kill him. And so they force the door, they clatter their way up the steps, they burst into Colony's room, they murder him, and then they hurl the body out from the window down into the street where the Duke of Geese is standing, and the Duke of Geese then tramples Coligny's corpse down. And worse is to follow, and it's described by a Huguenot-O-Loyer called Francois-Ottman, and he writes, Colony remained exposed to all sorts of ignominy, with some of his limbs cut off. He was dragged through the mud, and finally, after three days, was strung up by the feet at
住处门口的过道外，他们是奉国王查理九世的命令被派去保护科利尼免受天主教入侵者任何威胁的。但当吉斯公爵的手下到达时，火枪手们却说：“太棒了，让我们杀了他。”于是他们强行破门，踏着台阶发出哗啦哗啦的声响，冲进科利尼的房间杀了他，然后把尸体从窗户扔到街上，吉斯公爵正站在那里，吉斯公爵随即便践踏了科利尼的尸体。更糟糕的事情还在后头，一位名叫弗朗索瓦·奥特曼的胡格诺派律师对此进行了描述，他写道：“科利尼暴尸街头，受尽各种屈辱，四肢被砍掉了一些。他被拖过泥潭，最后，在三天之后，被倒吊在
Montfosson, where he remained for several days as a trophy in a mark of the cruelty and rage, which the people of Paris exacted on him, not just in life, but also on his dead body. And And Odomen's account of this massacre was one of many that were translated into English, and it was very, very influential. And you can tell how Marlowe drew on it very precisely for his play. So that's the end of Colony. But meanwhile, Gies's men are hunting down colonies, lieutenants and killing them. And at the same time, there's a kind of trigger effect.
蒙福孔的绞刑架上，作为战利品挂了好几天，这标志着巴黎人民对他的残酷和暴怒，不仅在他生前，死后对他的尸体也不放过。”奥特曼对这场大屠杀的记述是被翻译成英文的众多记述之一，它具有非常非常大的影响力。你可以看出马洛是如何极其精确地将其借鉴到他的戏剧中的。这就是科利尼的结局。但与此同时，吉斯的手下正在追捕科利尼的部下并杀死他们。与此同时，产生了一种触发效应。
Because in the Louvre, the Swiss guards who protect the king have woken up. up all the Protestant nobleman who are staying in the Louvre as Charles Inaut's guests, they have disarmed these Protestant nobleman and then slaughtered them en masse. And all the while, as described in Malle's play, so there's this kind of tolling of the bell, the toxin of the Church of Saint-Germain is sounding and it's a signal for a wholesale massacre, an uprising of Catholics across Paris against their Protestant neighbours. So this is this extraordinary dramatic event that plays such a massive part in the story of Europe in the 16th century, but also of Elizabethan England's relationship with its neighbours.
因为在卢浮宫里，保护国王的瑞士卫队已经叫醒了所有作为查理九世的客人在卢浮宫过夜的新教贵族，他们解除了这些新教贵族的武装，然后对他们进行了集体屠杀。与此同时，正如马洛的剧中所描述的那样，教堂的钟声敲响了，圣日耳曼教堂的警钟在鸣响，这是全城大屠杀的信号，是巴黎天主教徒针对新教徒邻居的一场起义。所以这是一个非同寻常的戏剧性事件，在16世纪欧洲的历史中占据了巨大的分量，同时也影响了伊丽莎白时代的英国与其邻国的关系。
So we're going to get right into the details of the massacre. This is a classic sectarian mob violence, but it's been masterminder, right? There are signals. There are very powerful people who are controlling. it. And there's a sort of deliberate cold-bloodedness to it, that there's been these years of tension and violence between Catholics and Protestants. But this is a genuine premeditated attempt to settle accounts once and for all. And basically to kill all the Protestants in Paris? Is that the, was that too strong? Well, I mean, the details of the slaughter are hideous.
所以我们要直接切入大屠杀的细节。这是一场典型的教派暴民暴力，但它是经过精心策划的，对吧？有信号。有非常权势的人在控制着它。其中有一种刻意的冷血，因为天主教徒和新教徒之间已经有了多年的紧张关系和暴力。但这是一种真正的、蓄意的试图一劳永逸地清算账目的企图。基本上就是要杀光巴黎的所有新教徒？是这样吗，这个说法是不是太强烈了？嗯，我的意思是，这场屠杀的细节是极其可怕的。
So maybe up to 5,000 Protestants murdered in Paris, tens of thousands. more in copycat massacres across France. And as you say, I mean, it is undoubtedly fueled by sectarian hatred. And a measure of this, I mean, it's really horrible is that a lot of the slaughter that is inflicted on the Huguenots, and I'm quoting here from the definitive new book on the massacre by Joanna Alet, and she writes that the Catholic slaughter of the Huguenots corresponded to a wish to destroy all chances of proliferation by the group that their murderers sought to eliminate. And so what that meant in effect was that Protestant men were not just murdered, they were castrated, that pregnant women had their bellies slashed open and the fetuses pulled out.
因此，巴黎可能有多达5000名新教徒被杀害，而在法国各地的效仿大屠杀中，还有成千上万的人丧生。正如你所说，我的意思是，这无疑是由教派仇恨所助长的。衡量这一点的一个标准，我的意思是，这真的很可怕，那就是对胡格诺派施加的大屠杀中，有很大一部分——我这里引用的是乔安娜·阿莱特关于大屠杀的权威新书，她写道，天主教徒对胡格诺派的屠杀符合“彻底消灭凶手们试图铲除的这个群体繁衍所有机会”的愿望。因此，这实际上意味着，新教徒不仅被谋杀，他们还被阉割，孕妇的腹部被剖开，胎儿被掏出来。
And that children were targeted for wholesale butchery, which was framed by Protestants understandably as a new massacre of the innocence. so when Herod sent his soldiers to slaughter the innocence in Bethlehem. And one of the Protestant narratives described how the Sen was full of empty children's cradles from which the assassins had torn the newborn in order to steal their swaddling clothes before drowning them. And there's another very notorious account written by a Calvinist pastor who described seeing a young child being held by a Catholic with a large beard. and this child was kind of gurgling with delight, as reached with his tiny fingers to play with the curls of the Catholic's beard,
儿童成了全面屠杀的目标，新教徒理所当然地将其描绘成新版的“无辜婴孩大屠杀”。就像当年希律王派遣士兵去屠杀伯利恒的无辜婴孩一样。其中一个新教徒的叙述描述了塞纳河畔布满了空荡荡的婴儿摇篮，刺客们从摇篮里撕扯出新生儿，偷走了他们的襁褓，然后将他们淹死。还有另一个臭名昭著的记述，由一位加尔文主义牧师撰写，他描述看到一个年幼的孩子被一个留着大胡子的天主教徒抱在怀里，
and then the Catholic hurled this small child to his death into the Sen. People may be saying, well, I mean, God, we've heard stories like this a thousand times on the rest of history, and is this not just pure Protestant propaganda, rather like the propaganda that you had in the 1640s about the Catholic uprising in Ireland, and there were claims that, you know, lots of Protestant propaganda. were being massacred and these hideous kind of often sexual kind of crimes and whatnot.
而这个孩子正发出快乐的咯咯笑声，用他那小小的手指去玩弄那个天主教徒胡须上的卷发，然后天主教徒将这个小孩子重重地扔进塞纳河致死。人们可能会说，“天哪，我们在历史节目里已经听过一千次这样的故事了，这难道不纯粹是新教的宣传吗？就像你在1640年代听到的关于爱尔兰天主教起义的宣传一样，当时有人声称，你知道，有大量的新教徒宣传。”新教徒正在被屠杀，还有这些可怕的、通常带有某种性色彩的罪行等等。
Is this more of the same or is there genuine substance in these claims? Well, Protestants are definitely writing these terms, but so too are Catholics. So here is a Catholic witness. Naked bodies lay pierced by a thousand stabs in the streets. No distinction was made for sex, age or the status of people. And there are scenes of completely emblematic horror which haunt the age. described by Catholics as well as by Protestants. So to give you some of these scenes of horror, it's a famous professor at the University of Paris who was murdered, defenestrated as Colony
这又是老一套，还是这些指控有着真正的实质内容？嗯，新教徒确实在写这些东西，但天主教徒也在写。所以这里有一个天主教见证人：“赤裸的尸体身上布满了上千处刺伤，横卧在街道上。不分性别、年龄或人们的社会地位。”而且还有一些象征着这个时代挥之不去的恐怖场景，天主教徒和新教徒都对此进行了描述。为了给你们举几个这样的恐怖场景：巴黎大学的一位著名教授被谋杀、抛窗虐杀（像科利尼一样被扔出窗外并开膛破肚）。然后他的尸体被学校的男孩们用鞭子抽打。所以这是一种颠倒乾坤的秩序的象征。有一个新教书商被活活烧死在他自己店铺里的书籍堆成的火堆上。还有一个女人被她的头发绑在巴黎圣母院的桥拱上，她在那里悬挂了三天，直到她丈夫的尸体被丢在她身上，把她拖入了塞纳河。
had been chucked out of a window and disemboweled. And his corpse is then lashed with whips by schoolboys. So it's a kind of emblem of order turned upside down. There's a Protestant bookseller who is burnt alive on a pyre fashioned out of the books from his shop. And there is a woman who was tied by her hair to the arch of the bridge by Notre Dame, and she hung there for three days before the corpse of her husband was dropped on top of her and dragged her down into the seine. Thus, they were united in their burial. I mean, some of these stories sound kind of too emblematic, perhaps to be true. But I think that you don't get stories like those coming from both sides of the sectarian divide, unless the scenes of slaughter really are horrific. And isn't one of the things that adds to it? The fact that when the news of the massacre first breaks, the reaction of a lot of French Catholics is not one of embarrassment or shame or anything like that, but unbridled delight and joy. Well, in France, I mean, the Catholics are, I mean, not all of them, but across cities in France, they are doing copycat massacres. But I think what's really shocking, and particularly to Protestants, but also actually to a lot of Catholics as well, is the reaction from the leading figures in the Catholic world. So the Pope ordered a Te deum to be sung, and he issued a commemorative medal, which showed an angel with a cross and a drawn sword killing heretics.
就这样，他们在葬礼上合葬了。我的意思是，其中一些故事听起来有点太具象征意义了，也许并非真实。但我认为，除非屠杀的场面确实骇人听闻，否则你不会在教派分歧的两边都听到这样的故事。难道其中一个加剧这种氛围的因素是，当大屠杀的消息最初传开时，许多法国天主教徒的反应并不是尴尬或羞耻之类的，而是难以遏制的狂喜和欢乐？嗯，在法国，我的意思是，天主教徒——并不是所有人，但在法国的各个城市，他们都在进行效仿性的大屠杀。但我认为真正令人震惊的，尤其是对新教徒而言，实际上也是对许多天主教徒而言，是天主教世界领袖们的反应。教皇下令高唱《感恩赞》，并发行了一枚纪念奖牌，上面描绘了一个天使拿着十字架和出鞘的剑在杀死异教徒。
So he's basically saying, this is great, fantastic, here's a medal. And Philip the second of Spain, the most powerful Catholic king, when he receives the news of the massacre, he goes through a monastery to pray and to give thanks to God. And then he returns to court and he speaks to the French ambassador and laughs and says that your master, Charles the 9th, well, he truly deserves his title of most Christian king for this godly massacre. So that's the initial response. But I do think that in due course, when the full details of what has happened, you know,
所以他基本上是在说：“这太棒了，太绝了，给你一枚奖牌。”而西班牙国王腓力二世，这位最有权势的天主教国王，当他收到大屠杀的消息时，他穿过修道院去祈祷并感谢上帝。然后他回到宫廷，对法国大使笑着说，你们的主人查理九世，为了这场神圣的大屠杀，确实当之无愧地被称为“最笃信宗教的国王”。这就是最初的反应。但我确实认为，随着时间的推移，当事情的所有细节开始浮出水面时，
happens starts to emerge, that there is a kind of feeling of embarrassment among Catholics who had celebrated the massacre as a kind of godly cleansing. And the excitement comes to be replaced almost by a sense of shame. And in fact, even at the time in Paris, there were Catholics who were appalled by the slaughter. So monasteries in the capital had provided shelter to Huguenotives. and individual Catholics too had very bravely offered shelter and refuge to Protestants who were fleeing mobs. And intriguingly, and this really complicates the kind of the sense that we have from Elizabethan propaganda about the Gies, this very powerful Catholic family. The Duke of Gies offered shelter to fugitive Catholics.
庆祝大屠杀为神圣净化的天主教徒中产生了一种尴尬的情绪。兴奋感几乎被一种羞耻感所取代。事实上，即使在当时的巴黎，也有天主教徒对这场屠杀感到震惊。因此，首都的修道院为胡格诺派提供了庇护，个别天主教徒也非常勇敢地为逃离暴民的新教徒提供了庇护和避难所。有趣的是，这大大复杂化了我们从伊丽莎白时代的宣传中对吉斯（这个非常有权势的天主教家族）的看法。吉斯公爵为逃亡的天主教徒提供了庇护。
And is this because basically it had got out of hand from what it originally planned? He'd planned this as an internal aristocratic. a settling accounts in an aristocratic feud and actually had then turned into something much bigger he'd lost control of it in a way I think also by offering Protestant nobleman against whom he doesn't have a grudge shelter he's getting you know he's building up credit with them
这是因为这基本上已经超出了最初的计划，变得失控了吗？他原本计划将其作为一场内部贵族在贵族世仇中的账目清算，结果却演变成了一场规模大得多的事件，他在某种程度上失去了对它的控制？我认为，通过为他没有怨恨的新教贵族提供庇护，他也在（你知道的）与他们建立人情关系，
so he's always kind of calculating so to that extent it may be a slightly kind of Machiavellian tactic I mean but it may also reflect a kind of genuine sense of compassion but I mean he wasn't very compassionate when he was trampling down the corpse of colony it has to be said I know The fact that Gies can commission the assassination of colony and then offer shelter to Huganoe fugitives later on, I think implies the fact that what we call the St. Bartholomew's Day massacre wasn't just a single massacre. It was a whole kind of confluence of blood feuds and pogroms. So Gies' attack on colony and his followers had fused with Charles the Ninth's very opportunistic murder of the Protestant nobleman in his home.
所以他总是在进行某种计算；从这个意义上讲，这可能是一种略带马基雅维利式的策略。我的意思是，这可能也反映了一种真正的同情心，但我的意思是，当他踩踏科利尼的尸体时，他可一点也不值得同情，这是必须承认的。我知道吉斯可以策划对科利尼的暗杀，随后又为胡格诺派难民提供庇护，这一事实暗示了我们所说的圣巴托洛缪节大屠杀不仅仅是一场单一的大屠杀。它是一系列血亲仇怨和暴力大清洗的交汇。因此，吉斯对科利尼及其追随者的袭击，与查理九世在其住所内对新教贵族的机会主义谋杀融合在了一起。
care and the news of these murders, I think then had in turn inspired a kind of sectarian bloodlust that had gripped the whole of Paris. And so lots of the Protestants who are killed, I mean, they're killed maybe because they're Protestant, but they're also killed probably. Maybe there was the kind of rival bookseller who got rid of that, you know, the Huguenot bookseller or whatever. They're the worst, aren't they, booksellers? Catholic booksellers.
而这些谋杀的消息，我认为反过来又激发了一种席卷整个巴黎的教派嗜血狂热。因此，被杀害的许多新教徒，我的意思是，他们被杀可能是因为他们是新教徒，但也可能是因为（也许）有某种竞争关系的书商除掉了那个（你知道的）胡格诺派书商之类的。他们是最坏的，对吧，书商？天主教书商。
And this is what Joanna Arlette in her recently published book. argues. And I think it's, you know, it's been a kind of revelatory text. People have kind of really accepted the force of that argument. But if you're looking at it from England, come on, if you're looking at it from England, though, I mean, you're not saying, oh, well, the extenuating circumstances. And actually, there are lots of different massacres here. And let's not conflate them. You're looking at this and you're saying, come on, we've been telling you for years that Catholics are evil conspirators who are plotting to kill us all. And guess what? They've just done it in Paris. Yeah. I mean, we know that if you see people from a different religious tradition as a kind of
这就是乔安娜·阿莱特在她最近出版的书中所争辩的。我认为这是一个具有启示性的文本，人们在很大程度上接受了这种论点的说服力。但是如果你从英国的角度来看，拜托，如果你从英国的角度来看，你不会说：“哦，好吧，有情有可原的情况，这里其实有很多不同的大屠杀，我们不要把它们混为一谈。”你会看着这一切说：“拜托，我们多年来一直在告诉你，天主教徒是邪恶的阴谋家，他们正密谋杀光我们所有人。你猜怎么着？他们刚刚在巴黎这么做了。”是的。我的意思是，我们知道，如果你把来自不同宗教传统的人视为一个整体，
mass and you're telling that they're going to do terrible things and then something terrible does get done in the name of that religion. Of course, you're tempted to feel that all your darkest suspicions have been conferred. And that's undoubtedly what happens with Protestants in England. And William Cecil, Elizabeth I was the first chief minister who we were talking about in our previous episode and who at the end of that episode became Lord Burley. So let's call him Burley. When he gets the news from Paris, he takes for granted that this is the manifestation of Satan's workings. And he, all along right the way from when he first became Elizabeth's first minister
并且你被告知他们会做可怕的事情，然后真的有可怕的事情以那个宗教的名义做了出来。当然，你会禁不住感到你最黑暗的怀疑得到了证实。这无疑就是英国新教徒的心态。伊丽莎白一世的首要首席大臣威廉·塞西尔——我们在上一集谈过他，在上一集末尾他成为了伯利勋爵。所以我们叫他伯利。当他从巴黎得到消息时，他理所当然地认为这是撒旦作为的显现。从他登上王位成为伊丽莎白的第一位大臣开始，他一直坚信存在一个旨在推翻英国新教事业的天主教国际阴谋。
when she ascended the throne, he has been convinced that there is a Catholic international conspiracy to overthrow the cause of Protestantism in England. And that foreign Catholics, like the Pope, like the Duke of Gies, like Philip II, all of whom, as he sees it, are implicated in either perpetrating or celebrating the Bartholomew's Day massacre, that they want to see the same thing happen in England and that they have a very dark and sinister plan, namely to murder Queen Elizabeth, who is a virgin queen, has no air, no Protestant air, no air at all, and to replace her on the English throne with her Catholic cousin, Mary Stewart, the Queen of Scots, who is a prisoner in England. And that the Pope in
并且外国天主教徒，比如教皇、吉斯公爵、腓力二世——在他看来，所有这些人都牵涉到策划或庆祝巴托洛缪节大屠杀——他们希望在英国看到同样的事情发生，并且他们有一个非常黑暗且阴险的计划，即谋杀伊丽莎白女王（她是一位贞洁女王，没有子嗣，没有新教继承人，根本没有继承人），并用她被关在英国作为囚犯的天主教表妹、苏格兰女王玛丽·斯图亚特取代她在英国王位上的位置。教皇
particular has made his ambitions for this plot very clear by two years before in 1570 excommunicating Elizabeth and telling Catholics with the full force of a papal bull that they have to work actively for her overthrow essentially kind of try to eliminate her maybe by assassination or whatever but doesn't the massacre in Paris suggest that actually the Catholic plotters ambitions might go further, that it's not just about assassinating one person, the queen, but they might, you know, if they got the chance, they would carry out a similar bloodbath, you know,
特别是通过在两年前的1570年将伊丽莎白逐出教会，并以教宗诏书的全部威力告诉天主教徒他们必须积极致力于推翻她（本质上是试图消灭她，也许通过暗杀或其他方式），已经非常明确地表明了他对这场阴谋的野心。但是巴黎的大屠杀难道不表明，天主教阴谋者的野心实际上可能走得更远吗？这不仅关乎刺杀女王一个人，如果他们有机会，他们还会在伦敦街头或类似地方进行类似的大血案？
in the streets of London or something. Yeah, absolutely. And he's bolstered in this view by the man who had been appointed by Elizabeth to serve as her ambassador in France, and this is none other than Francis Walsingham, who again, we met in the previous episode, like Cecil, Lord Burley. He's a very passionate Protestant. He's very subtle and implacable in his service to the Queen. He is a guy who is very skilled and practiced at interrogating Catholic spies.
是的，完全如此。而且伊丽莎白任命的驻法大使也增强了他的这种看法，这个人正是弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆。我们在上一集里也见过他，就像塞西尔（伯利勋爵）一样。他是一位充满激情的新教徒。他在为女王服务时既微妙又坚定不移。他是一个非常熟练且经验丰富、擅长审讯天主教间谍的人。
And so he is a very, very committed Protestant. And so it must have been incredibly unsettling for him to find himself in the middle of this kind of great pogrom of the Huguenots, particularly since his residence in Paris was very close to the church of Saint-Germain, so that one, you know, the tolling of the bell, signaling the onset of the massacre. And he had used his house as a kind of asylum for terrified Huguenots and also for English Protestants, so three English Protestants get killed in the massacre, which is pretty low. And that's because Walsingham has been able to provide them with sanctuary. He had also provided sanctuary to a Huguenot General who had been dragged out and hanged by
所以他是一个非常非常坚定的新教徒。发现自己身处这场针对胡格诺派的大清洗风暴中心，对F他来说一定极其令人不安，尤其是因为他在巴黎的住所离圣日耳曼教堂非常近，所以当教堂的钟声敲响、宣告大屠杀开始时，他也身在其中。他曾将自己的房子用作惊恐的胡格诺派以及英国新教徒的避难所——在屠杀中有三名英国新教徒被杀，这个数字相当低，那是因为沃尔辛厄姆能够为他们提供庇护。他还为一位被皇家军队拖出去并绞死的胡格诺派将军提供了庇护。
royal troops. And even though Charles the 9th had posted troops to guard Walsingham's residence, you know, there's no question that Walsingham had been in physical danger. He, his family, his servants, all the kind of people he'd offered refuge to. And for days after the massacre, as he was kind of driving round the streets of Paris in his carriage, the mob would hurl stones at him and yell abuse. And that I think the memories of everything that he witnessed stayed with him to the rest of his life, as they would. I think when you have 5,000 of your co-religionists slaughtered in the streets, I mean, that's something you're not going to get over easily. Exactly. Especially, well, if you're under threat yourself, right? Yeah, completely. And someone
尽管查理九世曾派部队保卫沃尔辛厄姆的住所，但毫无疑问，沃尔辛厄姆、他的家人、他的仆人以及他提供庇护的各类人当时都处于切实的危险之中。大屠杀发生后的几天里，当他坐着马车在巴黎街头穿行时，暴民们会向他投掷石子并大声辱骂。我认为他目睹这一切的记忆伴随了他余生，本该如此。我认为当你有5000名同信仰者在街头被屠杀时，这是你无法轻易忘怀的事情。完全正确。尤其是，如果你自己也受到威胁的话，对吧？是的，完全如此。还有一个人
else who was there with him was his brother-in-law, a guy called Robert Beale, who'd been serving Walsingham as his secretary in Paris. And Beale wrote a kind of memorandum, and he summed up the lessons that he was drawing it and applied it to England. I think at time and more than time for us to awake out of our dead sleep and take heed less like mischief, as has already overwhelmed the brethren and neighbours in France and Flanders embrace us. So in other words, what Catholics have done in Paris, if we give them the chance, they will do the same in London.
和他在那里的是他的小舅子，一个叫罗伯特·比尔的人，他曾在巴黎担任沃尔辛厄姆的秘书。比尔写了一份备忘录，总结了他从中吸取的教训并将其应用到英国：“我认为是时候、而且远远超过了我们要从沉睡中醒来，并当心不要让已经淹没法国和佛兰德斯的兄弟和邻居的同样祸害吞噬我们。”换句话说，天主教徒在巴黎做过的事，如果我们给他们机会，他们也会在伦敦如法炮制。
That appeal to wake up. We've been asleep. We must to wake out about dead sleep. I mean, that's so common in history. Wake up sheeple. Yeah. Exactly. So not long after the massacre, Walsingham comes back to London, doesn't he, from his ambassadorial posting. We talked in the previous episode about the parallels with the Cold War,
那种要求醒来的呼吁。“我们一直在睡觉。我们必须从沉睡中醒来。”我的意思是，这在历史中太常见了。“醒醒吧，沉睡的人们。”是的。完全正确。不久之后，沃尔辛厄姆就从他的大使岗位上回到了伦敦，不是吗？我们在上一集中谈到了与冷战的相似之处，
and he is like one of these American diplomats like George Kennan or somebody in the 1940s and 1950s, who had been in Moscow and then came back and said, right, I've seen the beast up close. It's actually worse than you think. We're in an existential life or death struggle with an implacable sinister adversary. He has come back, if anything, more hawkish. Yeah, definitely. Than when he went. And then Lord Burley gives him a new job and a very,
他就像是1940年代和1950年代乔治·凯农那样的一些美国外交官，曾在莫斯科待过，然后回来后说：“好吧，我已经近距离看到了这头野兽。它实际上比你想象的还要糟糕。我们正与一个不共戴天、阴险狡猾的对手进行一场生死存亡的生存斗争。”他回来后，甚至比他去的时候还要好战。是的，绝对如此。比他去的时候。然后伯利勋爵给他安排了一份新工作，一份非常
an absolutely crucial new job. Well, basically, Burley gives him his old job. So Lord Burley had been principal secretary to Elizabeth. And he's now, in 1572, he'd been promoted to become the Lord Treasurer. So effectively, Prime Minister, first Lord of the Treasury. And so Walsingham now is serving as principal secretary. which in effect means that in addition to handling all the kind of, you know, the foreign affairs and things like that, he is basically now the Queen's spymaster. And as the Queen's spy master, he is responsible for the monitoring and the repression of treasonous and activity in England.
绝对至关重要的新工作。嗯，基本上，伯利给了他自己的旧工作。所以伯利勋爵曾担任伊丽莎白的首席秘书。现在，在1572年，他已升任为财政大臣。实际上也就是首相、第一财政大臣。所以沃尔辛厄姆现在担任首席秘书，
So, to put it in modern parlance, he's the head of MI5. And he has a lot more tools to prosecute this war against sedition than Cecil had had at the beginning of his. term as Chief Secretary, because there's been kind of legislative beefing up since the Pope's excommunication of Elizabeth. So in 1571, one year after the papal bull excommunicating the Queen, Parliament had passed a new treason act, which made it illegal to call Elizabeth, and I quote, heretic, schismatic, tyrant, infidel, or an usurper of the crown. And clearly you don't criminalise people using language like that, unless they really have been using it. So clearly people have been calling Elizabeth, all those words. They also introduce an act against fugitives over the sea,
这意味着除了处理各种（你知道的）外交事务等事情之外，他基本上现在是女王的间谍头子。作为女王的间谍头子，他负责监视和镇压英国国内的叛国和颠覆活动。因此，用现代的说法，他是军情五处（MI5）的负责人。而且他拥有比塞西尔在他担任首席秘书任期之初时多得多的工具来起诉这场反对煽动叛乱的战争，因为自从教宗将伊丽莎白逐出教会以来，立法方面得到了加强。所以在1571年，即教宗发布将女王逐出教会的诏书一年后，议会通过了一项新的叛国法，规定称伊丽莎白为——我引述——“异教徒、分裂分子、暴君、异教徒或王位篡夺者”为非法。显然，除非人们真的在使用这些语言，否则你不会将使用这种语言的人定为刑事犯罪。所以很显然，人们一直称呼伊丽莎白那些词。他们还出台了一项针对海外逃亡者的法案，
which required the immediate return to England of anyone who had gone abroad without the specific permission of the government. And they also introduce the kind of laws I imagine, I mean, I doubt that Sarah Malalley, the new Archbishop of Canterbury, would personally be keen on these, but it might be one way to revive the Church of England because the laws that are passed under Elizabeth against recusants, they're called, so people who recusory, people who refuse to attend the services of the Protestant Church of England, they can be imprisoned without trial simply on the orders of the Privy Council. Just a question.
要求任何未经政府特许出国的人立即返回英国。他们还出台了我想象中的那种法律——我的意思是，我怀疑新坎特伯雷大主教莎拉·马拉利会亲自热衷于这些法律，但这可能是复兴英格兰教会的一种方法——因为在伊丽莎白统治下通过的针对“ recusants”（拒绝出席英国新教教会礼拜的人，被称为拒教者）的法律，他们可以在没有审判的情况下，仅凭枢密院的命令就被监禁。顺便问一下。
Elizabeth has been queen now for quite a while. 12, 13 years, right? Yeah. Why are there people still calling her a usurper of the Crown? That seems odd to me. I can understand there would be some Catholics who would call her a heretic or a schismatic. But she's been there a long time. She's been there longer than Mary was queen.
伊丽莎白当女王已经有一段时间了吧？12、13年了，对吧？为什么还有人叫她王位篡夺者？这对我来说似乎很奇怪。我可以理解会有一些天主教徒叫她异教徒或分裂分子。但她已经在位很长时间了。她在那里的时间比玛丽当女王的时间还要长。
Because if she is an illegitimate queen, as the Pope has said, one of the reasons for that illegitimacy isn't just her religion. It's also the fact that she is the daughter of a bastard, Anne Boleyn. So Anne Boleyn is seen as a whore. And so she is called the Great Whore and Elizabeth is called the Little Whore. Of course. I'm just surprised that it's now quite a long day. People don't live that long in the 16th century. It's quite a long time since Ambellin was around. You know, no memories die hard. But it's surprising to me that there is obviously a significant minority of people who are still questioning Elizabeth's right to rule. I don't think it's surprising at all because I think that the propaganda war on both sides is heating up. And that's always the way that when you have two ideologically opposed points of view. Both sides serve to radicalize the other. How are they exposed to Catholic propaganda? Because surely the government is straining every sinew to make sure that Catholic propaganda is not distributed. We are going to be coming to that because the elision between Catholicism
因为如果她是一个非法的女王，正如教宗所说，这种非法性的原因之一不仅是她的宗教信仰。还在于她是私生女安妮·博林的女儿。所以安妮·博林被视为妓女。因此她被称为“大妓女”，伊丽莎白被称为“小妓女”。当然。我只是惊讶于现在已经是相当长的一段时间了。人们在16世纪不会活那么久。自从安妮·博林存在以来已经过去很长时间了。你知道，根深蒂固的记忆很难消灭。但令我惊讶的是，显然仍有相当少数的人在质疑伊丽莎白统治的权利。我觉得一点也不奇怪，因为我认为双方的宣传战正在升温。当你有两个意识形态对立的观点时，情况总是这样。双方都在促使对方走向激进。他们是如何接触到天主教宣传的？因为政府肯定在竭尽全力确保天主教宣传不被散发。我们马上就会谈到这一点，因为天主教和叛国罪之间的混淆——那些法律相当明确地作出了这种混淆——是1570年代日益开始激发像沃尔辛厄姆这样的人斗志的事情。他们觉得英国的天主教徒和欧洲更广泛世界的天主教徒之间的这种阴谋感，非但没有像人们希望的那样消亡，反而变得越来越严重，天主教徒本质上正在被激进化，并且他们正在向英国以外的天主教大国寻求庇护和支持。这不仅是财务上的。
and treason, which those laws are pretty explicitly making, is something that increasingly by the 1570s is starting to animate wolf people like Walsingham. They feel that this sense of a conspiracy between Catholics in England and Catholics in the broader world in Europe that far from dying down, as the hope had been, that it's becoming worse and worse and worse, that Catholics are essentially being radicalized, and that they are looking to the Catholic powers beyond England. for succour and support. And that's not just financial.
这也是意识形态方面的。我们将看到这种说法的真实程度，因为这基本上就是今天这一集要讨论的内容。相反，对于像沃尔辛厄姆、塞西尔或伯利这样的人来说，他们对英国天主教徒越来越感到紧张，认为他们越来越具有威胁性，因为那些忠于自己信仰的天主教徒——即使他们同时忠于伊丽莎白——
It's also in terms of kind of ideology. And we will see the extent to which this is true, because this is pretty much what this episode today is going to be about. And conversely, for people like Walsingham, for Cecil, or Burley, again, they are becoming more and more nervous of English Catholics and seeing them as more and more of a menace, because Catholics who remain true to their faith, even if they are simultaneously loyal to Elizabeth,
正被新教政权这个紧张的安全机构塑造成外国势力的代理人、教皇的代理人、西班牙和法国国王的代理人。因此，沃尔辛厄姆作为首席情报官对女王的职责要求他不仅要密切关注英国的天主教徒，还要关注欧洲大陆。所以他实际上兼任了军情六处（MI6）和军情五处（MI5）的负责人。这对他是项挑战，因为尽管沃尔辛厄姆继承了伯利的情报网络，但这些网络并不像威尼斯的情报网络那样具有机构化。威尼斯历来在全欧洲雇用间谍、特工和线人。沃尔辛厄姆没有什么类似的东西。
and lots of English Catholics remain loyal to Elizabeth. They are being cast by this kind of, you know, the nervous security apparatus of the Protestant regime as agents of foreign powers, of agents of the Pope, of the kings of Spain and of France. And so therefore, Walsingham's duties as chief intelligents are to the Queen requires him to keep an eye not just on the Catholics in England, but also on the continent. And so effectively he is working his head of MI6 as well as of MI5. And this is a challenge for him, because even though Walsingham has inherited Burley's intelligence networks, these were not institutional in the way that, say, the intelligence networks of Venice were. So Venice had always employed spies and agents and informants across Europe. Walsingham doesn't have anything like that.
没有真正意义上的军情五处或军情六处供他接管。他必须从头建立。问题是，正如我们在上一集将英国比作21世纪的伊朗一样，英国非常孤立，而且相对贫穷，不像腓力二世雇用的特工那样拥有那种影响力和范围。你知道，腓力统治着这个庞大的欧洲帝国。他非常富有。他到处都有特工。他负担得起在那些他不直接统治的地方付钱给这些特工。女王很吝啬。你知道，她没有给沃尔辛厄姆提供大量的资金。但因为沃尔辛厄姆是一个坚定的信徒，
There isn't really a kind of MI5 or MI6 for him to take over. He's got to kind of build it. And the problem is that, you know, we compared England to Iran in the 21st century in our previous episode. England is very isolated and also relatively poor doesn't have the kind of the reach and the scope, say, of the agents employed by Philip II. You know, Philip rules this vast Europe-wide empire. He's very rich. He has agents everywhere. He can afford to pay those agents in places where he doesn't rule directly. The queen is stingy. You know, she's not providing Walsingham with enormous amounts of money. But because Walsingham is a true believer,
他把自己的个人财富投资在工作中。罗伯特·比尔（他的小舅子，他的秘书，从巴黎回来后担任了枢密院秘书）对沃尔辛厄姆在财务和意识形态上对这项事业的承诺表示了极大的钦佩。他写道：“沃尔辛厄姆秘书先生，在女王陛下的津贴和自己的钱包支持下，已经在海外40个地点招募了特工。”所以这相当令人印象深刻。其中一些特工甚至在外国政府的核心部门工作。因此，比尔特别指出了那些泄露了法国和苏格兰事务机密的人。所以在苏格兰宫廷和法国宫廷里有很多特工。
he invests his own personal fortune in his work. And Robert Beale, his brother-in-law, his kind of secretary, he's become secretary to the Privy Council on his return from Paris. He notes Walsingham's financial as well as ideological commitment to the cause with great admiration. He wrote, Mr. Secretary Walsingham, with Her Majesty's Allowance and his own purse, had recruited agents in 40 locations overseas. So that's pretty impressive. And some of these agents are working in the very heart of foreign governments. So Beale noted in particular those that betrayed the secrets of both the French and Scottish dealings. So lots of agents in the Scottish court and in the French court.
他将自己个人的财富投入到工作中。罗伯特·比尔（Robert Beale）是他的连襟兼秘书，从巴黎回来后，他成为了枢密院秘书。他非常钦佩沃尔辛姆对事业的资金投入和意识形态的忠诚。他写道："秘书沃尔辛姆先生在女王陛下的津贴和他自己出资的帮助下，在海外40个地方招募了特工。"所以这相当令人印象深刻。其中一些特工甚至打入了外国政府的核心。因此，比尔特别注意到那些泄露了法国和苏格兰交涉机密的人。所以在苏格兰宫廷和法国宫廷里有大量的特工。
But the hardest nuts to crack are the most menacing. And one of these is Spain, the most formidable power. The English intelligence services find it difficult to plant agents in Phillips court. and the other of course is the papacy, which is an institution with which England obviously has no diplomatic relations at all. And so Walsingham tries to get round this problem. Bill, again in his report notes, with money, he corrupted priests and traitors to portray the practices against this realm. And towards the end of the 1570s, he actually kind of contemplated a mad scheme to kidnap a papal nuncio to France. So he was going to use Huguenot pirates to kidnap this papal nuncio and bring him to England and kind of interrogate him. And Burley, who generally, I mean, loves a scheme to foil the Pope.
但最难啃的骨头也最让人心惊肉畏。其中之一就是西班牙，这个最强大的力量。英国情报部门很难在菲利普的宫廷里安插间谍。另一个自然是教皇国，英国显然与这个机构没有任何外交关系。因此，沃尔辛厄姆试图绕过这个难题。比尔在报告中再次指出，他用金钱腐蚀了神父和叛徒，让他们描绘针对这个王国的阴谋。在16世纪70年代末，他甚至产生了一个疯狂的计划：绑架一名教皇驻法国大使。他打算利用胡格诺派海盗绑架这位教皇大使，把他带到英国并进行审讯。而通常热衷于挫败教皇阴谋的伯利，
He said, no, this is mad. He nixed the plot. And so people may well, why he was Walsingham prepared to countenance such a kind of a reckless scheme? And the reason is that he fears a great new crisis is brewing for the queen and for the cause of true religion because he is the intelligence chief. he is closer to the reports of his agents now than Burley is. And he is abreast of very alarming news reaching him of developments in Rome, where it seems that a new stage in the Papacy's campaign against Elizabeth and Protestant England is being prepared.
他说，不，这太疯狂了。他否决了这个阴谋。因此人们可能会问，为什么沃尔辛厄姆准备默许这样一种轻率的计划？原因是他担心女王和真正宗教的事业将迎来一场巨大的新危机，因为他是情报主管。他现在比伯利更接近特工们的报告。他掌握了来自罗马的令人震惊的新闻进展，似乎教皇反对伊丽莎白和新教英国的运动正在筹备一个新的阶段。
And Rome, you know, it goes without saying for Protestants is the absolute sump of everything that is most hellish in Europe at this point. So there's a Protestant spy in England who ultimately ended up as a playwright, kind of like Marlame and Shakespeare. And he wrote this poem about Rome. It's the Sea of Sin, the beast with sevenfold head, the shop wherein all shame is sold and bought. The cup whence poison through the world is spread. And in the early 1570s, there is one particular poison that is giving Walsingham a special headaches. the most toxic poison in Christendom, in Walsingham's opinion.
你知道，对于新教徒来说，罗马不言而喻是欧洲此时此刻最地狱般的一切的绝对垃圾堆。所以英国有一个新教间谍，他最终成了一个剧作家，有点像马洛和莎士比亚。他写了一首关于罗马的诗。它是罪恶之海，七头之兽，买卖所有羞耻的店铺。是通过世界传播毒药的杯子。在16世纪70年代初，有一种特定的毒药让沃尔辛厄姆头疼不已。在沃尔辛厄姆看来，这是基督教世界中最剧烈的毒药。
And this is administered by the most brilliant, the most committed, the most dangerous of all Elizabeth's enemies. And these are enemies who are preparing for the first time if Walsingham's intelligence is accurate. To bring their campaign against the Queen directly to English. soil. And these enemies, Dominic, are enemies whose very name is sufficient to chill the soul of any devout Protestant. These enemies are the Jesuits. Oh no. Well, we'll come back after the break and we will welcome to the rest of history. Some of the worst people who've ever lived, the Jesuits. This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's. Now, when you have ambitions, being able to see the bigger picture is just so important. And history definitely teaches us that. My favorite example,
这是由伊丽莎白所有敌人中最聪明、最坚定、最危险的人管理的。如果沃尔辛厄姆的情报准确的话，这些敌人正在历史上第一次做准备。直接把他们针对女王的运动带到英国本土。多米尼克，这些敌人，他们的名字就足以让任何虔诚的新教徒魂飞魄散。这些敌人就是耶稣会士。哦，不。好吧，休息后我们将回来，欢迎来到历史的其余部分。一些有史以来最糟糕的人，耶稣会士。本集由劳埃德银行赞助播出。如今，当你拥有雄心壮志时，能够看清大局是如此重要。历史绝对教导了我们这一点。我最喜欢的例子，
not necessarily a brilliant man, but the Spanish conquistador Hernan Cortez. He was a visionary, he was an adventurer, but he also grasped that the empire of the Aztecs was vulnerable, and he took his men in land, and he was able to bring down the Aztecs with just a handful of men. And of course, this isn't just a problem for blood-soaked conquistadors. It is true for the rest of as well, which is where Lloyd's comes in. Their app helps you to see all your finances in one place so that you can feel clearer and more confident about what comes next. And rather like Cortez, you're managing the micro and the macro. So one moment, you might be managing day-to-day spending with budgeting insights using the app, or you might be getting guidance if you're thinking
不一定是多么杰出的人，但西班牙征服者埃尔南·科尔特斯。他是一个有远见的人，一个冒险家，但他也敏锐地察觉到阿兹特克帝国是脆弱的，他带着他的手下深入内陆，仅凭区区数十人就推翻了阿兹特克。当然，这不仅仅是沾满鲜血的征服者才有的问题。对我们其他人来说也是如此，这就是劳埃德银行发挥作用的地方。他们的应用程序帮助你在一个地方查看所有的财务状况，让你对接下来发生的事情感到更清晰、更有信心。就像科尔特斯一样，你要驾驭微观和宏观。所以上一秒，你可能还在用应用程序中的预算洞察来管理日常开支，下一秒，如果你在考虑
about starting a business. So whatever your next move looks like, you can bank on Lloyd's to help you make it with confidence. Visit lloydsbank.com. When WestJet first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was peak fashion, inline skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel.
创业，你就能获得指导。因此，无论你的下一步行动是什么，你都可以信赖劳埃德银行，它能满怀信心地助你实现。访问 lloydsbank.com。当西捷航空在1996年首次起飞时，那里的氛围有点不同。人们认为双层牛仔服是时尚的巅峰，旱冰鞋随处可见，三分之二的女性都留着“瑞秋”发型。
While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board. Here's to WestJetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. Welcome back to The Rest is here.
虽然这些东西留在了90年代，但有一点没有变，那就是当你登上西捷航空时感受到的那种温暖的感觉。为自96年以来一直陪伴我们的西捷航空干杯。和我们一起穿越回过去，并在 westjet.com 斜杠 30 年（westjet.com/30years）真正与我们同行。欢迎回到“其余皆历史”。
History, it is September 1579. We are in the sump of sin. We are in Rome itself. And we're at a dinner in a place called the English College. And this is a seminary where English students can train for the Catholic priesthood. And the guest of honour at this dinner is a man who Francis Walsingham, spymaster to Elizabeth I, regards as his most dangerous enemy, putting on one side, Mary Queen of Scots. And the name of this man is William Allen. He is a Catholic priest. He is a scholar. And like the co-founder of Golhanger, Tony Paster, he is a man of Lancashire.
历史，那是1579年9月。我们身处罪恶的泥潭。我们在罗马本身。我们正在一个叫做英国学院的地方参加晚宴。这是一所供英国学生接受天主教神职培训的神学院。这次晚宴的荣誉嘉宾是一个被伊丽莎白一世的间谍头子弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆视为最危险敌人的人，苏格兰女王玛丽暂且不论。这个人的名字叫威廉·艾伦。他是一名天主教神父。他是一位学者。就像戈尔汉格尔的联合创始人托尼·帕斯特一样，他是一个兰开夏郡人。
So a land of Lancashire educated at Oxford. So he's very like Tony Paster. Well, in some ways. Listeners can tell straight away that this is going to be a very bad man. Tell us about William Allen and why he's such a bad man, Tom. He's got a mole, hasn't he? He's got a reddish beard. I mean, it's all stacking up.
所以是一个在牛津接受教育的兰开夏郡人。所以他非常像托尼·帕斯特。嗯，在某些方面。听众马上就能听出这是一个非常坏的人。给我们讲讲威廉·艾伦，以及为什么他是个这么坏的人，汤姆。他长了一颗痣，对吧？他留着红褐色的胡子。我的意思是，这些特征都凑齐了。
He's very tall, he's very slim, he's in his late 40s. As you said, he'd been a brilliant student at Oxford, then he'd been a fellow at Oriel College. So a glittering academic career there. But because he's a very devout Catholic, when Elizabeth comes in and establishes the Protestant settlement, he can't put up with it. And so he leaves England and goes into permanent exile. And when he's in exile, he sets up seminaries with the aim of training English Catholic. priests who can then be sent back to England. And the first of these seminaries, he sets up at Daoie in the low countries and the second one at Rance in France. So you were asking,
他很高，很苗条，四十多岁。正如你所说，他曾是牛津大学的优等生，后来成为奥里尔学院的院士。所以在那里有着辉煌的学术生涯。但由于他是一个非常虔诚的天主教徒，当伊丽莎白上台并建立新教体制时，他无法忍受。因此他离开英国，开始了永久流亡。当他流亡时，他建立神学院，目的是培训英国天主教神父，然后可以把他们派回英国。他建立的第一所神学院在低地国家的杜埃，第二所在法国兰斯。所以你在问，
you know, how are people in England being kept abreast of all these developments? It's these priests who are being sent by, trained and sent by William Allen to England. Their aim is to kind of keep alive the flame of recusancy in England, to give mass to Catholics and to succour them and to let them know that they haven't been abandoned by the Catholic powers of Europe, but also if they can to try and to make conversions. So I guess, you know, again, pursuing the kind of Cold War analogy, KGB agents in Britain, they were kind of there to establish links with pre-existing communists, but also to recruit agents, say in, you know, Cambridge or the civil service or whatever.
你知道，英国的人们是如何了解所有这些发展的？正是这些由威廉·艾伦培训并派往英国的神父。他们的目的是在英国保持反抗新教的火焰，为天主教徒举行弥撒并给予他们救助，让他们知道他们没有被欧洲的天主教强国抛弃，同时如果可以的话，也试图进行皈依。所以我想，你知道，再次追溯冷战的比喻，英国的特工，他们去那里是为了与原有的共产主义者建立联系，但也为了招募特工，比如在剑桥大学或公务员队伍等等。
And so these priests have been going to England. obviously it's incredibly dangerous. But they come in large numbers. So the first four priests sent by Alan had arrived in England in 1574 and more had followed over the succeeding year. So by 1579, Alan has around 100 priests kind of working undercover in England, working to keep the flame of Catholicism alive. But now, you know, he's come to Rome to hold this dinner because he wants to turbocharged this mission. And he's come to Rome because he wants the Pope's personal backing for the acceleration of this mission. And nine days before this dinner with which we opened the second half, he'd had an interview with the Pope and the Pope had given the green light, had given
因此，这些神父一直在前往英国。显然这极其危险。但他们人数众多。艾伦派出的前四名神父于1574年抵达英国，随后几年又有更多人前往。因此到1579年，艾伦大约有100名神父在英国秘密工作，努力保持天主教的火焰不灭。但现在，你知道，他来到罗马举行这次晚宴，是因为他想为这项使命注入强心剂。他来到罗马是因为他希望获得教皇对加速这项使命的个人支持。在我们开启下半场的这次晚宴的九天前，他曾接受过教皇的接见，教皇开了绿灯，给予了
his blessing to this great project. And at the same time, Alan is a brilliant networker, very, very skilled in the arts of diplomacy. He's been assiduous in fostering close links with Philip the second of Spain and has actually persuaded him to sponsor an invasion of Ireland. And Elizabeth is the Queen of England and Wales, but she is also the Queen of Ireland. So this is an invasion of her backyard. And that evening at dinner, the dinner being held in Rome in mid-September 1579, Alan gives his fellow guests the great news. You know, the Pope is on board. He's given us more funding. invasion force with Spanish soldiers has landed in Ireland. It's all great. It's all kicking off. Things are really, really looking up. And Stephen Alford wrote a brilliant book about the kind of the espionage war called The Watchers. Yeah, The Watchers. Great book. He describes the speech that Alan gave that it must have been extraordinary and moving, revealing his persuasive power to inspire and to motivate, which no one ever doubts. I mean, that's why Walsingham sees him as such a dangerous. as four. And six priests sign up to the mission to England that very evening. And Alan says,
他对这个伟大的项目给予了祝福。与此同时，艾伦是一个出色的社交达人，在外交艺术方面非常非常熟练。他一直勤奋地与西班牙的菲利普二世建立紧密的联系，并实际上说服他资助对爱尔兰的入侵。伊丽莎白是英格兰和威尔士的女王，但她也是爱尔兰女王。所以这是对她后院的入侵。那天晚上的晚宴上，晚宴于1579年9月中旬在罗马举行，艾伦把这个好消息告诉了同桌的客人。你知道，教皇支持我们。他给我们提供了更多资金。载有西班牙士兵的入侵部队已在爱尔兰登陆。一切都很好。一切都在顺利进行。事情真的真的在好转。史蒂芬·阿尔福德写了一本关于间谍战的精彩书，叫《守望者》。是的，《守望者》。好书。他描述了艾伦发表的演讲，那一定是非同寻常且令人感动的，展现了他鼓舞人心和激励人心的说服力，这是任何人从未怀疑过的。我的意思是，这就是为什么沃尔辛厄姆认为他是一个如此危险的对手。当晚就有六名神父报名参加去英国的使命。艾伦说，
you will be going to England in, you know, just a few months at the start of 1580. So that's great. There are those six priests, but there is also another priest there who needs no encouragement whatsoever to plan for a mission to England. And this is a guy called Robert Persons, who is in his early 30s and like you, Dominic, he is a bailial man. And like you, he is bold. formidable and charismatic. Unlike you, however, he's a priest. He's a priest. He's a priest.
你将在1580年初的几个月内前往英格兰。所以这很棒。那六位神父暂且不表，但那里还有另一位神父，他根本不需要任何鼓励就会计划前往英格兰传教。这个人叫罗伯特·帕森斯（Robert Persons），三十出头，像你一样，多米尼克，他是一个精明强干的人。和你一样，他大胆、令人生畏且具有个人魅力。然而与你不同的是，他是一位神父。他是一位神父。他是一位神父。
He'd been ordained a priest only the year before, and not just any kind of priest, because specifically he had been ordained a priest of the society of Jesus. So, shorthand, a Jesuit. Right. So tell us a little bit about the Jesuits, because they are, they're about 40 years old at this point, aren't they? They're a religious order. Yeah.
他就在前一年才被按立为神父，而且不仅仅是普通的神父，具体来说，他是作为耶稣会的神父被按立的。所以，简而言之，他是个耶稣会士。没错。那么给我们讲讲耶稣会士吧，因为在这个时候他们大概才诞生40年，对吧？他们是一个宗教修会。是的。
Poverty, chastity, obedience. But what marks the mouth is this kind of fanatical loyalty to the Pope, right? Fanatical devotion to the Pope, I believe. Right. Monty Python would put it. They are the kind of the shock troops who have been formed to combat the Reformation. And their vocation is to win souls for Christ in this last era of a declining and grasping world. And so they've traveled to the limits of the world.
贫穷、贞洁、服顺。但他们的标志是对教皇的那种狂热忠诚，对吧？我相信是对教皇的狂热奉献。正如巨蟒剧团（Monty Python）所说的那样。他们是一支为对抗宗教改革而组建的突击部队。他们的使命是在这个衰落和贪婪世界的最后一个时代为基督赢得灵魂。所以他们旅行到了世界的尽头。
You know, they've gone to China. They go to Japan. people who've seen Shogun, the priests in that are Jesuits. Right. But persons who is English, he thinks, yeah, I mean, it's great sending priests off to China and Japan, but there's an obvious place where we need to make conversions, and this is my own native land, England. And so he has been pushing for this ever since he's become a Jesuit, so the whole year since his ordination.
你知道，他们去过中国。他们去过日本。看过电影《幕府将军》的人都知道，里面的神父就是耶稣会士。没错。但是身为英国人的帕森斯认为，是的，派神父去中国和日本固然很好，但有一个显而易见的地方我们需要去实现皈依，那就是我自己的祖国——英格兰。因此，自从他成为耶稣会士以来，他一直在极力推动此事，也就是他受任以来的这一整年。
and his superior, the Jesuit general, is reluctant because he doesn't really want to embroil the order in a mission that will be both very perilous and very controversial. I mean, it really is kind of plunging your hand into the magi mix. But Persons is very, very determined. And so he has joined forces with Alan. And the pair of them have been pushing for this kind of great mission to England. And Alan is very keen. He welcomes persons with open arms because he kind of admires them as the spiritual elite of the counter-reformation, the kind of the very sharpest edge. And so over the next few months after this dinner, Alan and Persons refine their plans.
而他的上级，耶稣会总会长却有些勉强，因为他并不真正想让修会卷入一项既非常危险又极具争议的任务。我的意思是，这真的就像是把手伸进马蜂窝里。但帕森斯非常非常坚定。因此他与阿伦（Alan）联手。两人一直在极力推动这项前往英格兰的伟大传教任务。而阿伦非常热心。他张开双臂欢迎帕森斯，因为他将他们视为反宗教改革的精神精英，是最尖锐的锋芒。所以在这次晚宴之后的几个月里，阿伦和帕森斯完善了他们的计划。
And the Pope gives them more funds. And secret documents are drawn up detailing lists of English Catholics who are in exile and so therefore readily contactable and who are ready to join the King of Spain in an invasion of England. and the conspirators, when they discuss this plot, they talk very openly because they know that they're among friends, that there are no kind of listeners eavesdropping. They talk openly of the joy that they would feel at seeing, and I quote, the Spaniards Lords of England and Elizabeth Tudor, Mistress Bess, as they call her, shaked of her estate. And William Allen leaves Rome with this kind of band of priests, this kind of shock force, of undercover agents who will be crossing into England. They leave Rome on the 25th of February 1580. So it is all kicking off.
教皇给了他们更多的资金。秘密文件被起草出来，详细列出了流亡的英国天主教徒名单，因此可以随时与他们取得联系，他们随时准备加入西班牙国王对英格兰的入侵。而阴谋者在讨论这个阴谋时，他们畅所欲言，因为他们知道自己身处朋友之中，没有人在偷听。他们公开谈论看到“西班牙人成为英格兰的主人，而他们称之为伊丽莎白·都铎——贝丝女主人——被赶下台”时他们所感到的喜悦。威廉·阿伦带着这群神父、这支将潜入英格兰的卧底特工突击力量离开罗马。他们于1580年2月25日离开罗马。所以一切都拉开了序幕。
But there is a particular man with them, isn't there, who listeners might want to pay attention to. And this is a man called Charles Sled, who has come along as a kind of fixer and a courier for them. And he's a sort of nondescript man. He's literate. He's very effective. He was once an apprentice to a merchant.
但他们中间有一个特定的人，对吧？听众可能会想关注他。这个人叫查尔斯·斯莱德（Charles Sled），他作为他们的联络人和信使一同前往。他是一个相貌平平的人。他识字。他非常高效。他曾是一名商人的学徒。
He had been in Rome since the previous summer. He had gone to St. Peter's for confession. And then he'd begun working as a servant for an English Catholic churchman in Rome. And how has he got involved? How has he got involved with this party? Why is he with them? Yeah, so he's in his mid-20s. He's English.
他自去年夏天以来就一直在罗马。他曾去圣彼得大教堂进行告解。然后他开始在罗马的一位英国天主教神职人员手下当仆人。他是怎么卷入进来的？他是怎么和这帮人混在一起的？他为什么和他们在一起？是的，他二十多岁。他是英国人。
He's come to Rome because he's a Catholic, or so he says. And he's taken confession, which demonstrates that he must be a Catholic. And so as an English Catholic, he's looking around for a job and he gets his job with an English churchman in Rome. And that means that when this English churchman hosts dinners, Charles Slead is in attendance. And William Allen and Robert Persons are regular attendees at these dinners. And Slead is there, you know, kind of like a waiter. He's kind of hovering with the wine. No one's paying any attention to him.
他来到罗马是因为他是一个天主教徒，或者他是这么说的。他做了告解，这证明他一定是个天主教徒。因此，作为一名英国天主教徒，他在到处找工作，并在罗马找到了一份为英国神职人员工作的工作。这意味着当这位英国神职人员举办晚宴时，查尔斯·斯莱德就会在场。威廉·阿伦和罗伯特·帕森斯是这些晚宴的常客。而斯莱德就在那里，你知道的，就像一个侍者。他在斟酒时四处转悠。没有人注意到他。
but of course he can listen to everything that is being said. And Alan does spot him and realizes that he's kind of very able. I mean, he's got all the qualities that you would want in a good servant. And so when Alan heads off with the Jesuits from Rome bound for England, Sled goes with them and often is riding ahead of them to fix rooms and to take letters for Alan and things like that. So by the 6th of April, before Alan arrives in Paris, Sled is already there. And then soon afterwards, he's in Rass, which is, of course, home of one of the two seminaries set up by Alan.
但当然，他能听到所说的一切。阿伦确实注意到了他，并意识到他非常能干。我的意思是，他具备一个好仆人所需要的所有品质。因此，当阿伦与耶稣会士从罗马出发前往英格兰时，斯莱德也随行，并且经常骑马走在他们前面，为阿伦安排房间、带信件之类的事情。因此，在4月6日之前，在阿伦抵达巴黎之前，斯莱德就已经在那里了。随后不久，他在兰斯（Rass），这当然是阿伦建立的两所神学院之一的所在地。
And then shortly after that, he pops up in Rouen, which is one of the main centres of English Catholic exiles in France. And everywhere he goes, he's carrying letters from Alan, and then he's taking letters back to Alan and the fellow conspirators. And he is attending their meetings. You know, he's laying the table, he's pouring the wine, he's serving the food, and he's listening to their homilies, and he's listening to all the details of their conspiracies. And he's a tremendous fellow to have around, and what a blessing it is for William Allen and
紧接着，他又出现在鲁昂（Rouen），这里是法国英国天主教流亡者的主要中心之一。无论他走到哪里，他都带着阿伦的信件，然后把回信带给阿伦和同谋者。他出席他们的会议。你知道的，他在摆桌子、倒酒、端上食物，听着他们的布道，听着他们阴谋的所有细节。有他在身边真是个了不起的家伙，对威廉·阿伦来说这真是个福气。
the Jesuits and the various priests to have him on hand. And then abruptly, in mid-May, sled vanishes. And people may be wondering, where has he gone, this trusted servant of William Allen? And I think that the answer to anyone who has read La Cary will come as no surprise whatsoever because on the afternoon of 17th of May, he pops up in London at the court in Westminster. And at the court in Westminster, Charles Sled, if that was indeed his name, is ushered into the presence of Francis Walsingham. I mean, listeners must have heard this coming when they heard you talking about his eye for detail. and he's brilliant master recall and he can keep a secret and all of this kind of thing.
还有耶稣会士和各路神父，有他在手边。然后突然间，在5月中旬，斯莱德消失了。人们可能会想，他去哪儿了，这个威廉·阿伦信任的仆人？我想任何读过勒卡雷（Le Carré）作品的人都不会感到惊讶，因为在5月17日下午，他突然出现在伦敦威斯敏斯特的宫廷里。在威斯敏斯特的宫廷里，查尔斯·斯莱德（如果这确实是他的名字的话）被带到了弗朗西斯·沃尔辛姆（Francis Walsingham）的面前。我的意思是，当听众听到你谈论他对细节的关注时，一定已经猜到了这一点。他拥有极佳的记忆大师般的水平，能保守秘密，诸如此类。
And effectively, what he now does is he hands over to Francis Walsingham all the details, all the inside dope on Alan and the Jesuit operation. So he's got lists of names, right? He's got, what, 300 English Catholic names on this list? These are people on whom Alan said, we can rely, we can contact these people, and Sled just gives all this to Francis Walsingham. Yeah, so it's details of the pensions. from the Pope and also very, very vivid physical descriptions.
实际上，他现在所做的是将所有细节、关于阿伦和耶稣会行动的所有内幕消息都交给了弗朗西斯·沃尔辛姆。所以他有名字名单，对吧？他有——什么？——这份名单上有300个英国天主教徒的名字？这些人是阿伦说过“我们可以信赖，我们可以联系这些人”的名单，而斯莱德把这一切都交给了弗朗西斯·沃尔辛姆。是的，所以那是来自教皇的津贴的细节，还有非常非常生动的身体外貌描述。
And Stephen Alford in The Watchers, which is absolutely, I mean, it's such a brilliant book. So gripping. He describes this list as the most complete reference work then available on Queen Elizabeth's enemies. So it's like downloading a massive database and then uploading it so that you know all your enemy agents that you're up against. Sort of WikiLeaks type thing. Yeah, so Robert Beale, so Walsingham's brother-in-law and kind of right-hand man, Secretary of the Privy Council. He writes it up and prepares it for distribution to particularly trusted members of the Privy Council. So it's so sensitive that not everybody gets it.
斯蒂芬·阿尔福德（Stephen Alford）在《观察者》（The Watchers）一书中——绝对的，我的意思是，这是一本太棒的书。太引人入胜了。他将这份名单描述为当时关于伊丽莎白女王敌人的最完整的参考资料。所以这就像下载了一个巨大的数据库，然后上传它，以便你知道你要对抗的所有敌对特工。有点像维基解密类型的东西。是的，所以罗伯特·比尔——沃尔辛姆的连襟、某种程度上的得力助手、枢密院秘书。他把它写下来，准备分发给枢密院特别信任的成员。所以它是如此机密，以至于不是每个人都能得到它。
And he just titles it priests and seminaries beyond the seas. You know, this is the key to combating these kind of enemory agents that are coming to England. And this dossier, when Walsingham reads it, and he's got Sled's reports of everything that these priests have been talking about in Rome, where Alan was talking about Spanish invasions of Ireland and England and so on. I mean, it just reinforces him in his conviction that England is at war. And that the priests that Alan is sending to England might protest that they are, they're not political agents. They are coming to minister to souls.
他给它起名为《海外的神父与神学院》。你知道的，这是打击来到英格兰的这些敌对特工的关键。当沃尔辛姆读到这份档案时——他手里有斯莱德关于这些神父在罗马谈论的一切的报告，阿伦在罗马谈到了对爱尔兰和英格兰的西班牙入侵等等——这只会巩固他坚信英格兰正处于战争状态的信念。阿伦派往英格兰的神父们可能会抗议说，他们不是政治特工。他们是为了灵魂的牧灵工作而来的。
But this is just equivocation. I mean, the Jesuits are notorious for equivocation among Protestants. And this is undoubtedly, I think, how Walsingham's. sees this kind of talk. Walsingham sees these priests and the Jesuits perhaps in particular as just arrant traitors. They're agents of the Pope, but they're also agents of the king of Spain, who is a foreign head of state, and they are conspiring against their anointed queen. So it's treason. So he's going to be targeting them not for their religious beliefs, but as traitors. And so this is why Elizabeth is not burning Catholics in the way that her
但这只是诡辩。我的意思是，在清教徒看来，耶稣会士以诡辩闻名。毫无疑问，我认为沃尔辛姆就是这样看待这种言论的。沃尔辛姆认为这些神父，特别是耶稣会士，简直就是彻头彻尾的叛徒。他们是教皇的特工，但他们也是西班牙国王的特工，西班牙国王是一个外国国家元首，他们在密谋反对他们受膏的女王。所以这是叛国罪。因此，他将把他们作为叛徒而不是因为他们的宗教信仰来进行打击。这就是为什么伊丽莎白不像她姐姐那样活活烧死天主教徒。
sister had done. She's learnt that lesson. That's bad. If you were up against enemies who are motivated by religious reasons, you don't condemn them for their religious reasons. You condemn them for treason, for being traitors to their anointed queen. So for Walsingham now, it's a manhunt, right, to track down these conspirators. Yeah, because he loves hunting. I mean, he's not a man who has much time for sport, but the sport he loves is hair coursing. So hunting hairs with dogs. But now, yes, basically it's a manhunt. And he's got two people in particular that he's after. So one of them is the baili or man you already mentioned, Robert Persons.
她吸取了那个教训。那样做不好。如果你面对的是出于宗教原因而受到驱使的敌人，你不要因为他们的宗教信仰而谴责他们。你要因叛国罪、因背叛他们受膏的女王而谴责他们。所以对沃尔辛姆来说，现在是一场搜捕行动，对吧，去追踪这些阴谋者？是的，因为他喜欢打猎。我的意思是，他不是一个有很多时间进行体育运动的人，但他最喜欢的运动是猎兔。所以用狗来猎取野兔。但现在，是的，基本上这是一场搜捕行动。他有两个特别要追捕的目标。所以其中一个是你们已经提到过的精明人罗伯特·帕森斯。
And the other is Robert Persons' deputy, who is a Londoner called Edmund Campion, who ends up becoming a great hero, doesn't he, to Catholics? Yes. So he's a very, very impressive man. I mean, almost everything about him is impressive. So unlike William Allen, Campion had initially accepted the Protestant settlement. He'd gone to Oxford, where he'd been the most brilliant student. of his day. He had formerly welcomed Elizabeth to the university, and Elizabeth had been very
另一个是罗伯特·帕森斯的副手，一个名叫埃德蒙·坎皮恩（Edmund Campion）的伦敦人，他最终成为了天主教徒心目中的伟大英雄，对吗？是的。所以他是一个非常非常了不起的人。我的意思是，他身上几乎所有东西都令人印象深刻。与威廉·阿伦不同，坎皮恩最初接受了宗教改革的妥协。他去了牛津大学，在那里他是他那个时代最聪明的学生。他曾正式欢迎伊丽莎白来到大学，伊丽莎白对他的印象非常深刻。
impressed with him. So too had William Cecil, who will become Lord Burley, and had kind of adopted him as a protege. But Campion starts to have doubts. And in 1569, he leaves Oxford and he goes to Dublin. So it's part of Elizabeth's realms. It is easier to be a Catholic there than it is in England at this point. And he starts to embark on a process of conversion, or maybe reconversion, you should say. And then he ends up in Dowie, which is one of William Allen's two seminaries. And in 1571, he's formally welcomed back into the Catholic Church. And two years later, he sets off on foot for Rome, where he becomes a Jesuit. And it's there in 1580 that he is recruited by persons for the mission to England.
威廉·塞西尔（William Cecil）也是如此，他后来成为了伯利勋爵（Lord Burghley），并将他收为门生。但坎皮恩开始产生怀疑。1569年，他离开牛津前往都柏林。所以它是伊丽莎白领地的一部分。此时在那里做天主教徒比在英格兰要容易一些。他开始着手皈依的过程，或者你也可以说是重新皈依。然后他最终来到了道埃（Douai），这是威廉·阿伦的两所神学院之一。1571年，他正式重返天主教会。两年后，他步行前往罗马，在那里他成为了一名耶稣会士。正是在那里，在1580年，他被帕森斯招募加入前往英格兰的特派团。
And actually, Campion hadn't wanted to go. He agreed with the Jesuit general that this was provocative to send the Jesuits into England. But, you know, he's taken his vow of obedience, so he has to go. And so he, and so off he sets. And you might think that if they're going undercover into England, that persons and Campion would, as they head from Rome towards the channel, that they'd be doing it in a kind of stealthy manner, a clandestine manner.
事实上，坎皮恩并不想去。他同意耶稣会总会长的看法，即派遣耶稣会士进入英格兰是一种挑衅。但是，你知道，他已经发出了服顺的誓言，所以他必须去。于是他出发了。你可能会认为，如果他们要潜入英格兰，帕森斯和坎皮恩在从罗马前往海峡的途中会以一种隐秘的方式、秘密的方式进行。
but not a bit of it. So Campion writes to his superior back in Rome, saying that they were being accompanied by something positively like a clamor, because everyone knows they're coming, they're massive celebrities, and their mission is seen by Catholics as something heroic and thrilling. And so despite themselves, they are celebrities even before they have arrived in England. Reckless. It is reckless, but maybe also a kind of challenge to the Protestant establishment, that we are coming as priests, and neither Walsingham nor Burley have any doubt as to particularly Campion's capabilities. He said he's intellectually brilliant. He has this amazing personal magnetism. He's a very warm, charming man. Everybody thinks this. And also this incredible
但一点也没有。因此，坎皮恩写信给他在罗马的上级，说他们的随行伴随着某种几乎可以说是喧嚣的声音，因为每个人都知道他们要来，他们是巨大的名人，他们的使命被天主教徒视为一种英勇和刺激的壮举。因此，尽管他们自己不这么想，但甚至在他们抵达英格兰之前，他们就已经成为了名人。鲁莽。这很鲁莽，但也许也是对新教建制派的一种挑战，即我们作为神父到来，无论是沃尔辛姆还是伯利，对于特别是坎皮恩的能力都没有任何怀疑。他说他智力超群。他有着惊人的个人磁场。他是一个非常热情、迷人的男人。每个人都这么认为。还有这种难以置信的
sense of conviction that is total, but not alienating in the way that a kind of fanatical conviction is. So he is very, he convinces people without seeming kind of swivel-eyed. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's a true believer, but he's not mad, which is an important distinction. You're not going to recoil from him in the street. Yeah. So all these qualities, of course, just make him seem more dangerous to Walsingham. And the fact that the Jesuits are coming to England at this specific moment in particular makes them seem sinister. So in Ireland, remember that invasion force that had been sent with the Spanish soldiers, they're still in the field and they've been swollen by Irish Catholic rebels who have flocked to the, actually the banner specifically of the Pope because an English papal nuncio has landed
坚定的信念，它是完全的，但又不会像某种狂热信念那样产生疏离感。所以他非常——他在没有显得狂热的情况下说服了人们。对，对，对。他是一个真正的信徒，但他并不疯狂，这是一个重要的区别。你不会在街上对他的出现感到畏缩。是的。所以所有这些品质，当然，只会让他在沃尔辛姆看来更加危险。而耶稣会士在这个特定时刻来到英格兰的事实，尤其让他们显得险恶。所以在爱尔兰，还记得那支带着西班牙士兵派出的入侵部队吗？他们仍在战场上，并且得到了蜂拥而至的爱尔兰天主教叛军的扩充，实际上他们聚集在教皇的旗帜下，因为一名英格兰教皇使节已经登陆
and is preaching holy war against the heretic Jezebel on the English throne. And so to quote Jesse Childs in her wonderful prize-winning book, God's Traitors, which is all about the recusants in Elizabethan England. From the government's viewpoint, it looked very much as though campion and persons were papal, Spanish agents bent on subversion, not conversion. The Jesuit say it's about conversion. Walsingham and Burley say, no, this is subversion. But they would be right to say that, wouldn't they? I mean, conversion and subversion of the same thing. If you are a Protestant minister of Queen Elizabeth, indisputably, if you are a Catholic priest, I think you could say,
并正在鼓吹对英格兰王位上的异端耶洗别（Jezebel）进行圣战。因此，用杰西·柴尔兹（Jesse Childs）在她那本关于伊丽莎白时代天主教不顺从者的精彩获奖著作《上帝的叛徒》（God's Traitors）中的话来说：“从政府的角度来看，坎皮恩和帕森斯看起来非常像是教皇和西班牙的特工，他们一心想要颠覆而不是皈依。”耶稣会士说这是关于皈依。沃尔辛姆和伯利说，不，这是颠覆。但他们这样说也是对的，不是吗？我的意思是，皈依和颠覆是一回事。如果你是伊丽莎白女王的新教大臣，毫无疑问，如果你是一个天主教神父，我想你可以说，
well, I'm doing God's will. But it's a fine distinction because the Pope has excommunicated the queen. I mean, that's surely the killer detail. You are not wrong, and Campion keeps very quiet about this. Because you cannot possibly say, oh, well, this is politically neutral. We're just, Dominic, you absolutely can, and they do. They do say that, but people don't believe them. Well, certainly the Protestant authorities don't believe them. And I suspect quite a lot of the Catholics don't believe them either. But this is what they are saying. So you can see how, essentially there is a kind of ideological opposition. And you can see that the question of what is their motivation, is it to convert or is it to
好吧，我在执行上帝的意愿。但这是一种微妙的区别，因为教皇已经将女王革除教籍。我的意思是，这绝对是致命的细节。你没有说错，而坎皮恩对此保持沉默。因为你绝不能说，哦，这在政治上是中立的。我们只是——多米尼克，你绝对可以这么说，他们也确实这么说了。他们的确这么说了，但人们不相信他们。好吧，新教当局当然不相信他们。我猜相当多的天主教徒也不相信他们。但这正是他们所说的。所以你可以看出，从根本上说存在着某种意识形态的对立。你可以看到，关于他们的动机是什么的问题——是为了皈依还是为了
subvert, is absolutely what is at stake in this whole episode, absolutely crucial. So they've arrived in the Channel ports. Now they've got the problem of how do they get over. Persons is the first to make the crossing and he sets out from Calais to Dover on the 16th of June 1580 and he has adopted a policy of wildly extravagant disguise. So he's dressed up as a kind of blood and thunder mercenary. He's got a leather coat that's trimmed with gold braid. He's got a feather in his cap, massively fanboyant. I think he's just a natural ham. It's a good disguise though. Yeah, it's a really good disguise because, you know, he's described
颠覆——绝对是整个事件中生死攸关的关键所在，绝对至关重要。所以他们抵达了海峡港口。现在他们面临着如何渡海的问题。帕森斯是第一个渡海的人，他于1580年6月16日从加来出发前往多佛，他采取了一种极其浮夸的伪装策略。他把自己打扮成某种血气方刚的雇佣兵。他穿着一件饰有金编织的皮大衣。他的帽子上插着一根羽毛，极其招摇。我想他只是一个天生的戏精。不过这倒是个好伪装。是的，这真的是个好伪装，因为，你知道的，他被
by a Catholic as being such a peacock, such a swaggerer. And so no one thinks for a minute that he could possibly be a priest, and so he crosses with no problem at all. Then Campion follows the week later, and he's disguised himself as a jeweller from Dublin, because of course he'd spent time in Dublin, so he's familiar with it. And he gets stopped because he resembles William Allen's brother, who had been on Sledd's list that he'd handed over to Walsingham. And so he does get apprehended, and for reasons that aren't entirely clear, they don't keep him. So he manages to carry on. from Dover and he arrives in London, where he rendezvouses with Persons, and Persons and Campion for the next few weeks are then touring safe houses across the capital. And they're preaching
一个天主教徒形容为一个如此骄傲、如此耀武扬威的人。所以没有人会认为他可能是个神父，于是他毫无问题地渡过了海峡。然后坎皮恩在一周后跟进，他把自己伪装成一个来自都柏林的珠宝商，因为他当然在都柏林呆过一段时间，所以他对那里很熟悉。然后他被拦了下来，因为他长得像威廉·阿伦的兄弟，而后者就在斯莱德交给沃尔辛姆的名单上。所以他确实被捕了，但由于原因不是很清楚，他们没有留住他。因此他设法继续从多佛出发，抵达伦敦，在那里他与帕森斯会合，而在接下来的几周里，帕森斯和坎皮恩一直在首都的各个安全屋巡回。他们进行布道
and they're celebrating Mass and they're hosting conferences with leading English Catholics, who are overjoyed to have these two very charismatic figures directly from the Pope in London. And Campion, you know, he understands Dominic where Walsingham and you are coming from. He knows that he is being accused of treason. And so he writes a formal letter explicitly denying this charge and insisting that he's come only, and I quote, to preach the gospel, to minister the sacraments, to instruct the simple, to reform sinners, to confute errors.
并庆祝弥撒，还与英国主要的领袖天主教徒举行会议，这些天主教徒非常高兴能在伦敦见到这两位直接来自教皇的极具魅力的风云人物。坎皮恩，你知道的，多米尼克，他理解沃尔辛姆和你的立场。他知道自己被指控犯有叛国罪。因此他写了一封正式信件，明确否认这一指控，并坚持说他来这里只是——我引述——“为了传福音、施行圣事、教导平民、改造罪人、驳斥错误”。
And his instructions to his fellow Catholics are, should I be captured, then send this letter to the Privy Council so that they can read and see what my motivation is. The problem with this is that it's a brilliantly well-written letter. I mean, everything Campion does is brilliant. And so Catholics read it and they go, oh, this is great. We should share it. And so they start copying it.
他给其他天主教徒的指示是：如果我被捕，就把这封信送到枢密院，这样他们就可以阅读并看到我的动机是什么。这里的问题在于，这是一封写得极好的信。我的意思是坎皮恩所做的一切都极其出色。所以天主教徒读了之后觉得，哦，这太棒了。我们应该分享它。于是他们开始复印它。
And so inevitably it falls into the hands of Walsingham's agents. To English Catholics, this letter is a great rallying cry. They find it very moving and inspirational. But to Walsingham and to the Protestant authorities more generally, this letter is not reassuring in the slightest. It seems a really terrifying provocation. And you can see why. So this is also what Campion has written.
因此，它不可避免地落入了沃尔辛姆特工的手中。对于英国天主教徒来说，这封信是一个伟大的战斗口号。他们发现它非常感人和鼓舞人心。但对沃尔辛姆和更广泛的新教当局来说，这封信一点也没有让人安心。它看起来像是一种可怕的挑衅。你可以理解为什么。所以这也是坎皮恩写下的内容。
The expenses reckoned. The enterprise is begun. It is of God. It cannot be withstood. So the faith was planted. So it must be restored. And how do you restore it? You restore it by getting rid of the Protestant Jezebel
费用已算清。事业已开始。这是天意。这是不可阻挡的。信仰就是这样种下的。它也必须这样被恢复。而你如何恢复它呢？你通过摆脱新教的耶洗别
and planting the Catholic Queen of Scots on the throne. And so unsurprisingly, among Protestants, the letter is very soon notorious, and they call it Campians brag. Do you think that's unfair? Do you think, I mean, he's not saying anything, just reading it. I mean, of course, there's a sort of, you might say there's kind of ideological arrogance to it. You know, we are. Well, he's a Jesuit. Yeah.
并扶植信仰天主教的苏格兰女王登上王位来恢复它。因此不出意料地，在清教徒中，这封信很快就臭名昭著，他们称之为“坎皮恩的夸耀”。你觉得这不公平吗？我的意思是，他没说什么别的，只是在读它。当然，你可以说这里面有一种意识形态上的傲慢。你知道，我们是。好吧，他是个耶稣会士。对。
But, but I mean. The logical arrogance is the whole point of being, I suppose, are kind of, you know, a part of a religious shock force. But I'm surprised. They're so provoked by it. I think it's because he was one of their own. He's writing in the style of an Oxford educated Protestant, but he's turning their weapons against them. I mean, again, to draw the analogy with the Cambridge traitors,
但是，但是我的意思是。这种逻辑上的傲慢正是成为某种宗教突击队成员的核心意义所在，我想。但我很惊讶他们对此反应如此激烈。我认为这是因为他曾是他们自己人。他用牛津受过教育的新教徒的风格写作，但他却把他们的武器对准了他们。我的意思是，再次类比剑桥叛徒，
that's what's kind of shocking to the British establishment was that chaps who'd been to decent colleges and belonged to clubs in St. James's had been working for the communists. And so I think there's an element of that that this is a very, very well-written letter. And they know that Campion is unbelievably smart. And therefore, you know, they can read between the lines. They know what he's getting at. And you compared him with the Cambridge traitors.
这正是让英国建制派感到震惊的地方——那些去过正派大学、在圣詹姆斯街加入过俱乐部的小伙子们竟然一直在为共产党人效力。所以我想这里面也有这方面的因素，这是一封写得极好的信。他们知道坎皮恩聪明得不可思议。因此，你知道，他们能够读出字里行间的深意。他们知道他的意图是什么。你把他和剑桥叛徒进行了比较。
I mean, he acquires this sort of, I don't know, Kim Filby style reputation, doesn't he? As a man who is, there's a kind of charisma that fascinates his enemies as much as his adherence. I mean, Kim Filby is an evil man who portrayed lots of people to their deaths. Campion is not doing that. Campion is a very brave, committed, heroic man, I think, who absolutely believes what he's doing. But he has a similar grip on the imagination that somebody like Filby had. I mean, if you're saying he's very charismatic, then yes. But he becomes a hero to Catholics because they see him, which I think he is, as a principled and heroic man who is tor. He leaves London, he tours Berkshire, Oxfordshire, Northamptonshire, so kind of the countryside. He's preaching in barns, and he's attracting ever-swelling congregations. You know, he has a touch of the stardust. People want to come and hear him. And undoubtedly, you know, he is getting converts.
我的意思是，他获得了某种，我不知道，类似于金·菲尔比式的声誉，不是吗？作为一个具有某种个人魅力的人，这种魅力吸引着他的敌人和追随者。我的意思是，金·菲尔比是一个邪恶的人，他出卖了很多人致死。坎皮恩没有这样做。我认为坎皮恩是一个非常勇敢、坚定、英雄式的人物，他绝对坚信自己在做的事情。但他对想象力的控制力类似于菲尔比那样的人。我的意思是，如果你说他很有魅力，那确实如此。但他成了天主教徒心中的英雄，因为他们把他看作是一个有原则、有英雄气概的人——我认为他确实是——他正在巡游。他离开伦敦，巡游伯克希尔、牛津郡、北安普顿郡，也就是乡村地带。他在谷仓里讲道，吸引了越来越多的信众。你知道，他身上有一种明星光环。人们都想来听他讲道。毫无疑问，你知道，他正在争取到归顺者。
And he's offering reassurance to Catholics who've been oppressed for a decade and a half now. And of course, he's always on the move. He's always having to put on disguises which Campion himself regards as ridiculous. but for months and months he's not caught and the whole Protestant spy agency are looking out for him. So that also adds to his kind of glamour, I think, the sense of him as a kind of secret agent as well as a priest. And then on the 27th of June 1581, so by this point he's been there almost a year, he throws down a very dramatic gauntlet by having an open challenge to the Queen printed and distributed across Oxford And again, he is kind of tweaking the nose of the Protestant establishment.
他为那些已经被压迫了十五年的天主教徒提供了安慰。当然，他总是在移动。他总是不得不进行伪装，坎皮恩本人觉得这很荒谬。但几个月下来他都没有被捕，整个新教间谍机构都在寻找他。所以这也在一定程度上增添了他的魅力，我觉得，那种既是特工又是神父的感觉。然后在1581年6月27日，也就是说此时他在那里已经将近一年了，他通过在牛津印刷并散发对女王的公开挑战书，下了一个非常戏剧性的战书。而且，他再次挑衅了新教建制派。
So he writes in this pamphlet, listen Elizabeth, Mighty Queen, The prophet in speaking to thee is teaching thee thy duty. That is bound to seem provocative, I think, to people like Walsingham. And so Walsingham says, come on, this is going beyond a joke. We have to get this guy. And it's clear by now that he is starting to kind of leave. a trail. And he's captured three weeks later on the 17th of July at a Requisance house called Lifford Grange in Berkshire. And actually, the people who find him were not specifically
因此他在小册子中写道：听着，伊丽莎白，伟大的女王，先知对你说话是在教导你的职责。我认为，对沃尔辛汉姆这样的人来说，这必定显得极具挑衅性。因此沃尔辛汉姆说，得了吧，这已经开玩笑道头了。我们必须抓住这家伙。到这时很明显他开始留下痕迹了。三周后的7月17日，他在伯克希尔一个名叫利福德格兰奇的天主教同情者的宅邸被捕。事实上，找到他的人并不是专门
looking for him. They were looking for other priests. But he is found after a two-day search, hiding in a priest hole with these two other priests. And the guy who has led them there is a very sinister figure called George Elliott. So he's the spy catcher. And he's a Catholic apostate who, you know, as is the way so often with upper states, are keen to, he's keen to prove himself more Protestant than the Protestants. And he has been playing on the Privy Council's paranoia. You know, he's been really bigging up all the stuff about plots and things funded by the Pope, assassinations of Elizabeth. I think coming up with material that wasn't actually true, and he very shrewdly tells Burley and Walsingham that they're in line to be murdered as well.
寻找他。他们在寻找其他神父。但在经过两天的搜寻后，他在一个神父藏身处被发现，和另外两名神父在一起。带他们去那里的那个家伙是一个非常阴险的人物，名叫乔治·埃利奥特。所以他是间谍搜捕者。他是一个天主教背叛者，你知道，就像那些上层背叛者经常做的那样，他渴望证明自己比新教徒更像新教徒。他一直在利用枢密院的偏执情绪。你知道，他一直在大肆宣扬那些关于阴谋以及教皇资助的事情、刺杀伊丽莎白的阴谋。我认为他编造了一些并非真实的材料，他非常精明地告诉伯利和沃尔辛姆，他们也有可能被谋杀。
So that kind of adds to that sense of urgency and trying to find. mind these priests. And so when Campion is brought out from the priest hole, you know, he is not treated well, which is what you would expect. So he's, his elbows are tied behind him. He's plonked on a horse. A sign is pinned to his hat, which reads Campion, the seditious Jesuit. And he is led straight to the Tower of London, where he is locked up in this hideous cell called Little Ease, which is a joke, because you can neither stretch nor rise to your feet. So he spends three days there. It must have been agony. But Little Ease is not to be the worst because the rack is waiting. And people may be wondering, well, you know, what's the status of torture in England at this time?
所以这在某种程度上增添了一种紧迫感，试图找到这些神父。因此，当卡皮恩从神父藏身处被带出来时，你知道，他没有受到好的对待，这也是你可以预料到的。所以他的手肘被反绑在背后。他被粗暴地放在一匹马上。他的帽子上别着一个牌子，上面写着“卡皮恩，煽动性的耶稣会士”。他被直接带到伦敦塔，关在一个叫做“小解脱”的可怕牢房里，这真是一个讽刺，因为你在里面既不能伸展身体，也不能站直。所以他在那里度过了三天。那一定非常痛苦。但“小解脱”还不是最糟糕的，因为刑具在等着他。人们可能会想，好吧，你知道，当时英国酷刑的地位是什么？
Torture is illegal. But at the same time, Walsingham is convinced that it has to be applied. So he had written to Burley in 1575, without torture, I know we shall not prevail. Dolly, very war on terror. Kind of Dick Cheney, isn't it? What's it? Enhanced interrogation techniques. It's a no-brainer. So I think for Walsingham, it's a no-brainer.
酷刑是非法的。但与此同时，沃尔辛姆确信必须动用酷刑。因此他在1575年写信给伯利，如果没有酷刑，我知道我们无法取胜。天哪，非常像反恐战争。有点像迪克·切尼，对吧？是什么来着？加强审讯技术。这是不言而喻的。所以我想对沃尔辛姆来说，这是理所当然的。
So Campion in his brag, that letter he'd written that was meant to be private, which had gone viral. He had declared his defiance of Elizabeth's judicial authorities by directly name-checking the prospect of torture. So he'd said, while we have a man left to enjoy your Tyburn where people hanged, or to be racked with torments, or to be consumed. with your prisons, you know, we will keep coming. And he was right to dread what the, what the Protestant authorities would do, because in the tower he is repeatedly racked. And it's so brutal that he loses the use of his pen hand. So people may remember that Guy Fawkes, you know, you can look at his signature before and after he's been racked. Campion has it so badly that he can't even sign a paper. And when he's not being tortured, he's being subjected
因此，卡皮恩在他的《狂言》中，即他写的那封本应是私人信件却不胫而走的信里。他公开宣称蔑视伊丽莎白的司法当局，直接点名提到了遭受酷刑的可能性。所以他说，当我们还有一个男人可以去泰本（人们被绞死的地方）享受绞刑，或者被酷刑折磨，或者被囚禁在你们的监狱里时，你知道，我们会源源不断地来。他预感到新教当局会做什么，这是对的，因为在塔里他一次又一次地受刑。它是如此残酷，以至于他失去了使用笔的手的能力。所以人们可能还记得盖伊·福克斯，你知道，你可以看看他受刑前后的签名。卡皮恩的情况如此糟糕，以至于他连字都签不了。当他没有受刑时，他正遭受着
to various inquiries. So there's a judicial inquiry led by. Robert Beale. There's a big theological debate which is staged in the parish church of the tower and Campion is only allowed the Bible so he's not allowed any other books, no other reference books. And then there's a public trial is staged in Westminster Hall in November 1581. And throughout all these processes, the core argument is the one that we were talking about earlier. Is his mission a pastoral one? Or is it? blatant treason. And this is, you know, they just keep going over and over and over it. And there's never really any doubt as to what the verdict is going to be. So on the 20th November,
各种审讯。因此，有一场由罗伯特·比尔领导的司法调查。有一场盛大的神学辩论在伦敦塔的教区教堂举行，卡皮恩只被允许使用圣经，不允许看任何其他书籍，没有其他参考书。然后，1581年11月在威斯敏斯特大厅举行了一场公开审判。在所有这些过程中，核心论点就是我们之前讨论过的那一个。他的使命是牧灵的吗？还是明目张胆的叛国？这就是，你知道，他们只是不停地一遍又一遍地讨论。对于最终的判决会是什么，从来没有什么真正的疑问。所以在11月20日，
Campion is convicted, not of heresy, not of any crime of conscience, but as an offender against a statute against treason that had been passed in the reign of Edward III, 220 years before. So he is convicted as a traitor. And on the 1st December, he suffers the death of a traitor. So he is lashed onto a hurdle. He is taken from his prison to Tyburn, which is now Marble Arch in London, but was the traditional place for executions. And there he suffers the hideous, hideous death of a traitor. So he's hanged until he is almost dead.
卡皮恩被定罪，不是因为异端，也不是因为任何良心罪，而是作为220年前爱德华三世统治时期通过的一项叛国罪法规的违法者。因此，他被判定为叛国者。12月1日，他遭受了叛国者的死刑。因此，他被绑在木栅栏上。他被从监狱带到泰本，也就是现在伦敦的大理石拱门，但当时那是传统的处决地点。在那里，他遭受了可怕的、可怕的叛国者之死。所以他被绞首直到奄奄一息。
He's then cut down. He is still alive as his bowels and his genitals are cut off and pulled out. and burnt in front of him. And then when he's dead, his body is quartered and the various quarters are dispatched to gateways around London. And Walsingham and Burley and the Privy and the Privy Council take a very, very grim satisfaction in Campion's fate because it draws what seems to be a line under what had been a very grim year.
他随后被放下来。当他的肠子和生殖器被割下、拽出并在他面前焚烧时，他仍然活着。然后当他死后，他的尸体被切成四块，各个部分被运送到伦敦周边的城门。沃尔辛姆、伯利和枢密院对卡皮恩的命运感到非常非常严厉的满意，因为它似乎为极其严峻的一年画上了一个句号。
So first, that rebellion in Ireland, we talked about, the Spanish troops, the papal nuncio, that has been suppressed. It took place at a place called Smirwick and County Kerry and all the Spanish troops had been satisfyingly massacred. And now the most dangerous papist agent that has been sent to England under Elizabeth has been captured, convicted and killed. And of course, Persons is still on the scene, but he manages to slip away. and the flow of priests does continue into the country for the rest of Elizabeth's reign. But I think that Walsingham and his men now feel that they have the measure of what is going on. And over the course of Elizabeth's reign, 471 priests will end up being captured and 116 of these will be executed.
首先，我们讨论过的爱尔兰叛乱、西班牙军队、教皇使节，已经被镇压了。它发生在一个叫斯米尔威克和凯里郡的地方，所有的西班牙军队都令人满意地遭到屠杀。现在，伊丽莎白统治下派往英国的最危险的天主教特工已经被捕、定罪并处决。当然，帕森斯仍然在现场，但他设法溜走了。在伊丽莎白统治的剩余时间里，神父源源不断进入国内的情况仍在继续。但我认为沃尔辛姆和他的手下现在觉得他们已经摸清了情况。在伊丽莎白统治期间，最终将有471名神父被捕，其中116人被处决。
And the reason that the numbers are so high is because neither side is willing to, to abandon its respective strategy. Because both sides, I think, feel that the benefits they secure from what they're doing outweighs the costs. So for Walsingham's men, they are stopping the proselytization of potential Catholics. It's destroying a foreign-funded campaign of subversion. Yeah. For the Catholic priests, their deaths enshrines them as martyrs and gives them what Protestants had been given under Mary Tudor. So to this day, Edwin Campion and a lot of the Catholic priests who were executed under Elizabeth, they're saints.
数字如此之高，是因为双方都不愿放弃各自的策略。因为我认为双方都觉得他们从所做的事情中获得的利益超过了成本。对于沃尔辛姆的人来说，他们正在阻止潜在天主教徒的皈依。这摧毁了一场由外国资助的颠覆活动。是的。对于天主教神父来说，他们的死使他们成为烈士，并给了他们新教徒在玛丽·都铎统治下所得到的东西。时至今日，埃德温·卡皮恩和许多在伊丽莎白统治下被处决的天主教神父，他们都是圣徒。
They kind of give their names to rooms in Catholic schools and things like that. But the consequence for the climate in Elizabethan England is undoubtedly to generate a sense of paranoia, as you always do when there's a kind of espionage war going on. And because this is a specifically Christian espionage war, it gives people on both sides, Catholics and Protestants a sense that they're living in the shadow of a kind of great cosmic drama. But a drama that's not just playing out in the shadows, Tom. So it's not just a story about spies and back rooms and priestholes and double agents, is it? It's also a story of swashbuckling sea dogs. It is. Right.
他们给天主教学校的房间等地方命名。但对伊丽莎白时代英国气候的影响毫无疑问是产生了一种偏执感，每当有某种谍战发生时总是如此。因为这是一场明确的基督教谍战，它让双方的人，天主教徒和新教徒，都有一种生活在某种宏大宇宙戏剧阴影下的感觉。但这不仅仅是一出在阴影中上演的戏剧，汤姆。所以这不仅仅是一个关于间谍、后室、神父藏身处和双重间谍的故事，对吧？这也是一个关于海上勇士的故事。确实如此。对吧。
And that's what we'll be turning to next time. So in the next episode, from the coast of California to the Straits of Magellan, we will be venturing onto the Marine Front in the ideological struggle between Protestantism and Catholicism. And in particular, we will be heading onto the marine front. the Pacific Ocean with one of the greatest figures of the Elizabethan age. Not uncontroversial figure these days. And that is Sir Francis Drake. So loads of excitement, loads of rough action, loads of swashbuckling, swordplay to come next time. Now, if you remember the rest of history club, you may well be on the Pacific Ocean as we speak.
这就是我们下次要转向的话题。所以在下一集中，从加利福尼亚海岸到麦哲伦海峡，我们将涉足新教与天主教意识形态斗争中的海洋前线。特别是，我们将前往海洋前线。太平洋，伴随着伊丽莎白时代最伟大的人物之一。如今这也是一个颇具争议的人物。那就是弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。因此，下次将有大量的兴奋、大量的惊险动作、大量的勇士剑术。现在，如果你还记得历史俱乐部的其他人，当你说话时，你很可能已经在太平洋上了。
You may have not even be listening to this because you may be already listening to that episode right now. because you can, of course, because you get all the episodes early. If you're not a member of the Restis History Club, and you'd like to be part of our own shadowy cabal of sinister conspirators, then you just need to head to the restishistory.com to sign up. And of course, that's the only way you'll get the host of unbelievable benefits. And there are other ways to sign up, but only through the website, the restishistory.com, do you get the cornucopia of the lights that we offer our members?
你甚至可能没有在听这个，因为你可能现在就已经在听那一集了。因为你当然可以，因为你可以提前听到所有剧集。如果你不是“历史俱乐部”的会员，并且想成为我们阴暗的阴谋集团的一员，那么你只需要前往the restishistory.com注册。当然，这是获得大量难以置信的好处的唯一途径。还有其他注册方式，但只有通过网站the restishistory.com，你才能获得我们向会员提供的丰富好礼。
And, of course, the other thing you can do is to sign up to our free newsletter. and there you get all kinds of absolutely riveting articles, interviews, book extracts and more. We're also doing a live show, aren't we, about the ultimate Victorian adventure, which is the Abyssinian Expedition Expedition of 1868, all kicked off when the Abyssinian Emperor wrote letters to Queen Victoria, and she neglected to reply, and he got in a massive strop, and chaos ensued. Yeah, it's absolutely amazing story. It's one of the most lurid, implausible and entertaining of all. 19th century imperial adventures. So I'm really looking forward to the show. It's very flashman, isn't it? There's a flashman book about it, Flashman on the March. Yeah, it's the ideal
当然，你还可以做的另一件事是注册我们的免费简报。在那里你可以获得各种绝对引人入胜的文章、采访、书摘等等。我们还在做一个现场节目，不是吗，关于终极的维多利亚时代探险，也就是1868年的阿比西尼亚远征，这一切都是由阿比西尼亚皇帝写信给维多利亚女王开始的，而她没有回信，他勃然大怒，随后陷入了混乱。是的，这是一个绝对惊人的故事。这是19世纪所有帝王冒险中最耸人听闻、最不可信且最有趣的冒险之一。所以我真的很期待这个节目。这非常像“弗莱什曼”，对吧？有一本关于它的弗莱什曼书，《进军途中的弗莱什曼》。是的，这是理想的
flashman story if you like Flashman. And even if you don't, it's still brilliant. Anyway, that is at the South Bank in London on Friday the 4th of September, and you can get tickets once again at the restis history.com. I think you should just bookmark the restishtry.com and buy everything it's got to offer. So on that bombshell, we'll be back next time with Sir Francis Drake. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
弗莱什曼故事，如果你喜欢弗莱什曼的话。即使你不喜欢，它依然很棒。无论如何，那是9月4日星期五在伦敦南岸举行的活动，你同样可以在the restishistory.com上买到票。我想你应该把the restishtry.com加入书签，并购买它所提供的一切。带着这个重磅消息，我们下次将带着弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士回归。再见。拜拜。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。